ich komme nun zur Tagesordnung hier
werden Zusatzpunkt 6 Tagesordnungspunkt
Buchstabe b und Buchstabe C sowie
Tagesordnungspunkt 40 Buchstabe d
abgesetzt
ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 10a
und 10b Beratung mehrerer Vorlagen zur
Einführung eines Bürgergeldes
wir werden später drei namentliche
Abstimmungen durchführen
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne nun die Aussprache und das
Wort hat zu Beginn der Bundesminister
für Arbeit und Soziales Hubertus Heil
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ich hatte gestern die
Gelegenheit ein Startup-Unternehmen
gestern Nachmittag in Berlin Wedding zu
besuchen das Unternehmen heißt Factory
ist ein Unternehmen das mittels einer
digitalen Plattform
Zulieferteile für
Maschinenbauunternehmen vermittelt das
Unternehmen hat 35 Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeiter und hat sich entschieden in
den letzten Jahren fünf
langzeitarbeitslose Menschen
einzustellen
langzeitarbeitslose Menschen die vom
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt profitieren mit
lohnkostenzuschüssen ich habe gestern
auch die Gelegenheit gehabt mit dreien
dieser Menschen zu sprechen dabei war
ein Mann der sage und schreibe 15 Jahre
lang arbeitslos war und das nicht weil
er zu faul war
sondern weil er ein Schicksalsschlag
hatte hätte Bankkaufmann gelernt hat
gearbeitet der ist dann erkrankt hat
seine Arbeit verloren es war eine
langjährige Erkrankung es ging
irgendwann gesundheitlich besser aber
jahrelang sich die fingerbund
geschrieben nach langen Jahren der
Arbeitslosigkeit ohne eine Chance auf
Arbeit wieder zu bekommen weil er zu
lange draußen war er hat meine Maßnahme
bekommen Bewerbungstraining aber nicht
wirklich Arbeit finden können meine
Damen und Herren dieser Mann ist heute
in der Buchhaltung des Unternehmens
dessen wertvoller Mitarbeiter in Zeiten
in denen händeringend Arbeits- und
Fachkräfte gesorgt werden und was wir
mit dem Bürgergeld machen ist dass wir
den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt in Fristen
damit wir Menschen wie diesen eine
Chance auf selbstbestimmtes Leben in
Arbeitgeber meine Damen und
das Bürgergeld meine Damen und Herren
ist die größte sozialstaatsreform seit
20 Jahren wir verfolgen als
Bundesregierung als Koalition damit vor
allen Dingen zwei Ziele ja es geht darum
dass Menschen die in existenzielle Not
geraten sind verlässlich und so
unbürokratisch wie möglich abgesichert
werden aber das reicht uns nicht wir
wollen nicht nur Schutz geben in Zeiten
der Not wir wollen Chancen auf den
selbstbestimmtes Leben schaffen ich habe
es eben am Beispiel dieses Mannes am
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt beschrieben aber
wir sagen das auch mit Blick auf die
Realität der Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit in
Deutschland wenn es so ist dass zwei
Drittel der Langzeitarbeitslosen
Menschen heute kein abgeschlossenen
Berufsabschluss haben und sie im alten
Hartz-IV-System dann hin und wieder
vielleicht mal den Hilfstätigkeiten
vermittelt werden aber das Jobcenter sie
nach ein paar Monaten wiedersieht und
sie nicht dauerhaft nachhaltig in Arbeit
vermittelt werden dann ist im System was
falsch mit dem Bürgergeld ändern wir das
wir schaffen die Chance dass Menschen
nicht in Hilfstätigkeiten ver werden
müssen sondern ein Berufsabschluss
nachholen können um dauerhafte und
Arbeit zu sein dass es auch ein Beitrag
für Fachkräfte und Arbeitskräfte
für den Bürgergeld reagieren wir auf
zwei fundamentale Veränderungen erstens
ist der Arbeitsmarkt heute ein völlig
anderer als vor 20 Jahren damals hatten
wir Massenarbeitslosigkeit heute in
vielen Bereichen Arbeits- und
Fachkräftemangel und zweitens ist es
wichtig aus den Erfahrungen der Krisen
der letzten Jahre auch der aktuellen
Krise zu lernen wenn es darum geht für
weniger Bürokratie im System und für
mehr Respekt für die Menschen zu sorgen
für Notlagen meine Damen und Herren
brauchen wir Lösungen die funktionieren
so unbürokratisch und so
bürgerfreundlich wie möglich wir sorgen
mit den Bürgergeld dafür dass wir
überflüssige Bürokratie in den
Jobcentern abbauen damit die
Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeiter in der
Jobcenter die übrigens eine
hervorragende Arbeit leisten tatsächlich
sich auf das Wesentliche konzentrieren
können ein Beispiel ist das was die
Jobcenter immer gefordert haben zum
Beispiel eine Bagatellgrenze für
Kleinstbeträge wo Menschen mit
Bescheiden belästigten überzogen werden
dann lohnt weder Aufwand noch nutzen das
schaffen
vor allen Dingen meine Damen und Herren
aber sorgen wir für angemessenen Schutz
ein wichtiger Teil der Reform ist die
Erhöhung des Regelsatzes es geht darum
dass das Bürgergeld was die Erhöhung und
Anpassung der Regelsätze betrifft der
Inflationsentwicklung zukünftig nicht
mehr hinterherlaufen das ist gerade
jetzt besonders wichtig aber ich sage
auch klar und deutlich damit kann es
nicht getan sein die Qualität eines
Sozialstaats bemisst sich nicht allein
an der Höhe des sozialen Transfers
sondern die Qualität des Sozialstaats
bemisst sich vor allen Dingen daran wie
sehr er in der Lage ist Menschen zu
einem selbstbestimmten Leben am Arbeit
zu bringen und ich sage es noch mal ein
Beispiel des Mannes den ich eingangs
genannt habe wir hatten erzählt was er
in den 15 Jahren erlebt hat wie er sich
die fingerbund geschrieben hat wie ihm
die Decke auf den Kopf gefallen ist und
dem Mann geht es heute besser in Arbeit
er sagt ich fühle mich wertgeschätzt ich
leiste was ich habe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren für die
Mehrheit der Menschen in Deutschland ist
Arbeit mehr als Broterwerb es ist Geld
verdienen aber es ist Teilhabe am
gesellschaftlichen Leben und damit
sorgen auch mit Bürgergeld dafür das
Leistungssystem
und wir setzen Anreize ein
Berufsabschluss nachzuholen ermöglichen
das nicht nur wenn wir das einmal bei
Menschen erlebt hat die ein
Berufsabschluss verpasst haben die sich
dann wieder aufrappeln das ist sehr
anstrengend und wir wollen das
leistungszielt und das auch mit
finanziellen Anreizen belohnt wird mit
dem Weiterbildungsgeld wir werden dafür
sorgen und da bin ich den
koalitionsfraktion sehr dankbar dass wir
uns darauf verständigt haben dass wir
Zuverdienstgrenzen im Bürgergeld erhöhen
damit Leistung sich lohnt das war nicht
nur ein Anliegen der FDP aber die FDP
hat sich besonders dafür eingesetzt ganz
herzlichen Dank dafür
und jetzt meine Damen und Herren muss
ich an die Adresse der cdu/csu
Bundestagsfraktion mal meiner
Verwunderung Ausdruck bringen dass sie
heute den Antrag stellen dass nur der
Regelsatz erhöht wird wenn sie
wochenlang rumlaufen und sagen mit den
Bürgergeld lohnt sich Arbeit nicht mehr
und gleichzeitig nur den Regelsatz
erhöhen dann ist ein gewisser logischer
Bruch muss ganz deutlich zu sagen
denn Arbeit muss ein Unterschied machen
arbeit muss sich lohnen in Deutschland
und dafür sorgt die Koalition deshalb
haben wir den Mindestlohn erhöht meine
Damen und Herren ab 12 Euro und die
cdu/csu hat nicht mitbestimmt
deshalb kämpfen wir für mehr
Tarifbindung und brauchen auch da noch
ein bisschen Unterstützung kann die
Union sich auch verdient machen deshalb
haben wir das Wohngeld heute auf der
Tagesordnung gerade in diesen Zeiten
deshalb haben wir Beiträge und Steuern
für Geringverdiener gesorgt den Arbeit
müssen Unterschied machen aber in diesen
Zeiten in denen die gesellschaftliche
Stimmung angespannt ist aufgrund der
Krise werden und dürfen keine
demokratischen Demokraten zulassen das
geringverdienende Menschen gegen
bedürftige Menschen ausgespielt werden
wir müssen die gesamte Gesellschaft im
Blick haben und dieses Land
zusammenhalten
durch mit zwei Kritikpunkten noch
auseinandersetzen die heute auch
vorgetragen werden zum einen die
sogenannte Karenzzeit in der wir uns
erstmal wir Menschen bedürftig geworden
sind nicht angucken die Angemessenheit
des Wohnraums weil wir eben Menschen
nicht verunsichern wollen die Not
geraden sind dass sie auch noch ihre
Wohnung verlieren sondern sich darauf
konzentrieren können wie dein Arbeit zu
kommen und richtig wir greifen kleines
Erspartes auch nicht an das haben wir
übrigens mit der CDU mal eingeführt vor
zwei Jahren weil wir da in der Krise
erlebt haben wie das ist wenn
soloselbstständige beispielsweise auf
einmal in Not geraten und dann ihr
ganzes Erspartes aufbauen müssen das ist
auch eine Frage des Respekts vor
Lebensleistung leistung muss sich lohnen
in Deutschland
dann wird noch behauptes gäbe keine
Sanktionen mehr richtig ist dass wir die
Sanktionen Mitwirkungspflichten auf die
Bereiche konzentrieren auf die
hartnäckigen Fälle in das notwendig ist
aber der Geist des Bürgergeldes meine
Damen und Herren ist nicht der dass wir
alle Menschen die langzeitarbeit zu sind
unter Verdacht Stellen zu faul zu sein
zu Arbeit die meisten wollen arbeiten
der geistesbürgergelds ist der der
Solidarität des Zutrauens der Ermutigung
und deshalb haben wir gute Gründe dass
heute zu beschließen am Montag ist der
Bundesrat dran vielleicht gibt es eine
Mehrheit dafür wir haben gute Argumente
zu überzeugen unsere hat es ausgestreckt
wir haben viele Anträge des Bundesrates
übernommen auch von unionsgeführten
Ländern ich hoffe darauf Vernunft statt
auf Parteitaktik denn da sitzen
Ministerpräsidenten Ministerpräsidenten
und nicht Mitarbeitern
aber falls es am Montag noch keine mehr
den Bundesrat gibt wird die
Bundesregierung den
Vermittlungsausschuss anrufen dann haben
wir die Gelegenheit in einem schnellen
Verfahren dafür zu sorgen dass das
Bürgergeld am 1 Januar in Kraft tritt es
wird dann gestuft umgesetzt damit die
Jobcenter nicht überlastet werden aber
wichtig ist meine Damen und Herren dass
wir die im Blick haben um die es geht
die Menschen die jetzt auf das
Bürgergeld angewiesen sind herzlichen
Dank
Hubertus Heil der Bundesarbeitsminister
mit seinen Erläuterungen zum
bürgergeldgesetz und jetzt folgt ihm
Hermann Gröhe stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der Unionsfraktion der wie
wir wissen aus dem Interview vor wenigen
Minuten da eine deutlich andere Position
hat
Kolleginnen und liebe Kollegen ja Herr
Minister es geht um Menschen wie den von
Ihnen genannten Langzeitarbeitslosen die
wir besser in Arbeit vermitteln besser
unterstützen wollen und deswegen ist es
richtig dass sie den sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt den wir gemeinsam
geschaffen haben in Fristen aber es ist
völlig verfehlt dass sie in der Bereich
der Integration in Arbeit 600 Millionen
Euro kürzen wollen tun sie doch nicht so
als hilft ein neuer Name wenn sie beim
Geld für die Jobcenter kürzen für uns
als Union war stets klar Vorfahrt für
Vermittlung wir halten am fordern fest
aber wir müssen beim fördern besser
werden wir wollen nicht das alles so
bleibt wie sie es permanent unterstellen
bis heute verweigern sie jede sachliche
Debatte über die grundsätzlichen
Webfehler ihres Gesetzes ich dachte
zunächst da sei die ampelangst vor
Argumenten inzwischen weiß ich sie haben
sogar vor unseren fragenangst es ist
doch ungeheuerlich dass sie es der
Opposition verweigern dem
Bundesrechnungshof in einer Anhörung
dieses Parlaments zu befragen eine
Institution der das Grundgesetz
richterliche Unabhängigkeit zuschreibt
und sie wollen diese Antworten nicht im
Parlament hören unglaublich
glauben Sie eigentlich im Ernst glauben
Sie im Ernst die Arroganz der Mehrheit
im Bundestag erhöht die Chancen auf eine
Mehrheit im Bundesrat wer empfiehlt ihn
eigentlich so absurde Strategien das ist
doch unglaublich ja die Zeit wird knapp
wir wollen am 1 Januar bessere
Bedingungen für die Menschen die
langzeitarbeitslos sind aber der
kabinettszeitplan ist der
kabinettszeitplan der Ampel der
parlamentszeitplan ist der
parlamentszeitplan der Ampel wir haben
zu keiner Zeit irgendetwas verzögert im
Gegenteil es waren die
arbeitsministerinnen und Minister der
Union die vor einer Woche an Sie als
Fraktionen der Ampel geschrieben haben
um welche grundsätzlichen Bedenken es
ging wir wollten uns ein
Vermittlungsverfahren ersparen wir
wollten in die Gelegenheit geben sich zu
korrigieren Sie haben die ungenutzt
verstreichen lassen
und trotz aller persönlichen
Herabsetzungen sei mal darauf
hingewiesen die Personalräte der
Jobcenter drängen auf eine Verschiebung
sie schreiben lesen Sie den Brandbrief
sie drängen darauf
sie nein ich weiß dass sie das Herr dürr
also im Schulhof gilt wer brüllt hat
Unrecht für Herrn bürgelt das sogar im
Parlament meine Damen meine Herren also
das originell
also jetzt lassen sie nicht mal etwas zu
den Personalräten sagen dass die FDP
sich nicht dafür interessiert ist ja in
Ordnung aber so kalt schnäuzig wie die
SPD mit diesen Personalräten umgeht
sollten Sie aufhören andere über
Mitbestimmung zu belehren das ist die
Zeit da schreiben ihnen Personalräte
dass die Kolleginnen und Kollegen den
Tränen nahe sind und schlagen vor
vorzuziehen die Regelsatzerhöhung das
ist der Vorschlag von Friedrich Merz sie
wischen dies vom Tisch meine Damen meine
Herren wir sind für die möglichst
zeitnah Erhöhung darum geht es es geht
niemanden darum irgendjemand aus
gegeneinander auszuspielen es geht darum
ein Jahr zu haben zu den höheren
Regelsätzen und in den Blick zu nehmen
die Lage der Menschen mit geringem
Einkommen und Herr Klingbeil ich zitiere
ihren Vorgänger Sigmar Gabriel er sagt
er sei kein besonderer Fan des
Bürgergelds dann geht's weiter es führe
dazu Zitat klingen bei ist
Zitat Gabriel Zitat dass diejenigen die
als wenig qualifiziertem Handwerk
arbeiten in Zweifel keinen ökonomischen
Anreiz mehr haben arbeiten zu gehen ihr
Vorgänger nach ihrem Niveau müssten sie
jetzt Genosse Trump sagen das ist nur
Art peinlich und Christian Lindner
erklärt wenn der Regelsatz steigt dann
müssen der Grundfreibetrag erhöht werden
damit räumt er genau ein dass wir recht
haben ich befürchte nur der
FDP-Vorsitzende Lindner wird ihm
vorwerfen das sei schäbigkeitswettbewerb
so ist das wenn man ein bisschen
schizophren argumentiert sie lehnen es
ab sie wollen es heute ablehnen den
Regelsatz zu erhöhen aber dann haben sie
am Montag kein Recht die Länder damit
unter Druck zu setzen man müsse ihrem
Gesetz uneingeschränkt zustimmen sonst
enthalte man Arbeitslosen die fällige
Erhöhung vor heute gab heute gibt es
einen Namensliste wer war dafür und wer
war dagegen das ist sehr eindeutig
und da sie am liebsten streite schreien
sage ich Ihnen mit Denkverboten kommen
sie nicht weiter und ich sage sehr
deutlich wir wollen nicht lediglich eine
Erhöhung der Regelsätze wir wollen auch
wir haben Vorschläge gemacht wir lehnen
auch nicht alles bei Ihnen ab um das
klar zu sagen
Hinzuverdienstgrenzen erhöhen haben wir
uns als Unionsfraktion zu bekannt nein
das stimmt einfach nicht aber sie packen
die zentralen Webfehler nicht ein es
geht eben im Kern um ein Schonvermögen
bei einer Bedarfsgemeinschaft mit zwei
Kindern von 150.000 Euro die man
besitzen kann und trotzdem Bürgergeld
bekommen kann die Mehrheit der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer kann
von einem solchen vermögen nur träumen
und wissen Sie sie gefährden damit die
fair mit die gefährden damit die
Fairness in diesem Land aber was viel
schlimmer ist sie gefährden damit die
Chancen auf Vermittlung in Arbeit
erlauben Sie mir einen Landrat zu
zitieren es ist unerklärlich dass in
einer Zeit in der die Gesellschaft zur
Bewältigung von Krisen und ihren
Aufgaben zwingend das
Arbeitskräftepotenzial erhöhen muss
die Wege aus der Arbeitslosigkeit
eingeschränkt und die Wege in die
Arbeitslosigkeit erleichtert werden
dieser Landrat Peter Pohlmann ist
Mitglied der SPD in Niedersachsen Herr
Klingbeil wahrscheinlich auch so
eingenossen Tram es ist doch
ungeheuerlich sie preisen sich die
Preisen sich für die angeblich größte
sozialstaatsreform aber sie wissen Weg
die Kritik des deutschen Städte und
Gemeindebundes sie wissen Weg die Kritik
des Deutschen Städtetages sie wissen Weg
die Kritik des Landkreistages wie viel
ideologische verbotheit braucht man
eigentlich um somit der Kritik
derjenigen umzugehen die unseren
Sozialstaat vor Ort tragen mit dieser
Arroganz bringen Sie den Sozialstaat
nicht nach vorne mit dieser Arroganz
werden sie scheitern
Hermann Gröhe war das stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der Unionsfraktion hat
einige Punkte hier natürlich auch noch
mal betont die wir schon im Interview
mit ihnen gehört haben heute um viertel
vor neun wo es auch ich sag's mal
vorsichtig lebendig zugehen Britta
Hasselmann ist die nächste Rednerin in
dieser Aussprache der ja nicht nur der
Gesetzentwurf der Koalition zugrunde
liegt sondern auch drei Anträge aus der
Linksfraktion und einer aus der
afd-fraktion zum Thema Bürgergeld Gesetz
und jetzt wie gesagt Britta Hasselmann
die Vorsitzende der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
die Diskussion über eine dieser größten
Sozialreformen der letzten Jahrzehnte
nämlich das Bürgergeld ist eine sehr
wichtige und sie wird sehr kontrovers
geführt
lieber Hermann Gröhe ich habe sie hier
schon sehr oft reden gehört und ich
schätze sie sehr aber ihre Rede hat
gezeigt wie schwer es ihnen fällt die
Position von Friedrich Merz und Söder zu
vertreten
meine Damen und Herren wer keine
Argumente in der Sache hat verliert sich
im Verfahren und das wird dem Anliegen
das mit dem Bürgergeld verbunden wird
mit den vielen Menschen die davon
profitieren werden und die betroffen
sind in keiner Weise gerecht meine Damen
und Herren und
einst fest Friedrich Merz spitzt zwar
die Lippen öffentlich ja und er geht
sich in Vorurteilen gegenüber Menschen
die betroffen sind die von
Arbeitslosigkeit betroffen sind die arm
sind die in prekären
Beschäftigungsverhältnissen Leben schürt
sozial Neid ohne Ende eine solche
soziale Kälte in Krisenzeiten kaum zu
ertragen und verantwortungslos aber hier
im Parlament
wir im Parlament kneift er heute es ist
auch einfacher Interviews zu geben bei
denen keiner widersprechen kann meine
Damen und Herren weil heute wären wir
mit ihren Argumenten die sie öffentlich
führen mit Ihnen hier scharf ins Gericht
gegangen meine Damen und Herren
aber aber meine Damen und Herren es geht
halt um die Lebenswirklichkeit die sind
in diesem Land verschieden
und wie soll jemand der in einer ganz
anderen Lebenswirklichkeit lebt und sich
vielleicht überlegen muss ob er zur
Party mit dem Privatjet oder mit dem
Auto oder den Zug fliegt sie soll
Erziehenden Frau versetzen die überlegen
muss ob sie ein paar neue Turnschuhe für
das Kind kaufen kann oder ob sie
vielleicht heute einen Ausflug machen
kann in einer Eisdiele und mehr als drei
Kugeln Eis für ihre drei Kinder drin
sind
auch nicht erwarten dass man sich da
reinversetzen kann aber was ich von
ihnen erwarte ist Respekt Respekt vor
der Lebenslage eines jeden Menschen und
den haben sie nicht meine Damen und
Herren
das Bürgergeld ist viel mehr als eine
Regelsatzerhöhung und deshalb
beschließen wir es heute auch insgesamt
es ist eine Reform des Arbeitsmarktes es
wird Veränderungen bringen denn meine
Damen und Herren
das Bürgergeld schafft Qualifizierung
und Weiterbildung es schafft
Perspektiven für Menschen und
selbstverständlich geht es um
Vermittlung aber es geht nicht mehr
einfach nur um bloße Vermittlung sondern
um Qualifizierung und Beschäftigung
meine Damen und Herren es geht um
Fortbildungen es geht um
kooperationsperspektiven und wenn man
keine Ahnung hat vom Thema dann kann man
das vielleicht nicht sehen aber es ist
der Ansatz die Brücke für Menschen in
den Arbeitsmarkt zu verbessern indem man
ihn Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung
gibt und nicht einfach nur auf prekäre
Arbeits- oder
hilfsarbeitsangebote setzt und das ist
mit der bürgergeld-reform verbunden und
da kann niemand dagegen sein und wenn
man die Rede von Karl Josef Laumann im
Bundesrat gehört hat hat er uns doch
gerade da unterstützt Hubertus Heil bei
der Frage wir brauchen mehr
Qualifizierung Weiterbildung wir
brauchen Fortbildung und und und und
alles wichtige Maßnahmen von denen es
nichts mehr zu hören auf dieser Seite
denn Sachargumente spielen keine Rolle
meine Damen und Herren
das ist auch eine enorme Chance zur
Entbürokratisierung es ist eine enorme
Chance auch für Wirtschaft Handwerk und
Industrie denn die warten alle auf
facharbeitskräfte wir haben eine
fachkräftekrise in dieser Gesellschaft
und es ist wichtig deshalb diese beiden
Fragen zu verknüpfen all das ist mit dem
Bürgergeld verbunden und sie wissen es
im Kern auch meine Damen und Herren und
die Anpassung der Regelsätze in dieser
Krisenzeit ist natürlich mehr als
notwendig denn viele der Menschen die
auf Grundsicherung angewiesen sind
wissen doch am 20 des Monats nicht mehr
wie sie bis zum 31 kommen angesichts der
Verteuerung der Lebenssituation und
deshalb meine Damen und Herren es ist
insgesamt ein gutes Paket eine soziale
Reform die eben auch Vermittlung auf die
Frage von Qualifizierung und
Beschäftigung auf Ermutigung und Hilfe
und deshalb lassen Sie uns darüber
weiter diskutieren wir hoffen auf die
Zustimmung und Unterstützung vieler
danke
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion
Norbert Kleinwächter
[Applaus]
werte Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir stehen an
der Seite derer die hart arbeiten die
einen Schicksalsschlag erleiden und dann
auf unsere Hilfe angewiesen sind
deswegen befürworten wir die Erhöhung
des Regelsatzes im SGB 2 meine Damen und
Herren denn es sind nicht unsere
Arbeitslosen die für diese völlig irren
Preissteigerungen verantwortlich sind
die Verantwortung dafür tragen unsere
Bundesregierung die EU-Kommission und
die Europäische Zentralbank mit ihrer
völlig Viren Niedrigzins und
transformationspolitik und vor dieser
Politik müssen wir die Menschen und
unsere Arbeitslosen auch schützen
[Applaus]
aber das Bürgergeld geht ja noch viel
weiter
das Bürgergeld hilft nicht denen die
arbeiten wollen hilft nicht denen die
Leistung zeigen wollen das Bürgergeld
unterstützt diejenigen die nicht
arbeiten wollen und deswegen ist es
unsozial sie bringen Leistungen aus an
Leute die nicht arbeiten wollen auf
Kosten und Lasten derer die jeden Morgen
zur Arbeit gehen einstempeln ausstempeln
die Verantwortung tragen in ihren
Berufen die auch ein Risiko eingehen in
ihren Berufen ihr Risiko einen Job zu
verlieren ihr Risiko vielleicht ihren
Wohlstand zu verlieren wenn Sie
selbstständig sind ihr Risiko ihre
Gesundheit zu verlieren ein Risiko geht
ein bürgergeldempfänger nicht ein meine
Damen und Herren
und schauen wir uns doch mal die
Verbesserungen an sie nennen das ja so
die sie da vorschlagen
wem nützt es denn dass man ein
Einfamilienhaus im Münchner nobel vor
Ort behalten kann mit 140 Quadratmeter
Wohnfläche an einem Wert von über einer
Million Euro ist dieser Mensch bedürftig
nein er ist es nicht wem nützt es denn
dass man in unbegrenzter Höhe wohnen und
Heizkosten jetzt nennen sie es ja
Übernahme angemessene Heizkosten bei
einer unangemessenen Wohnfläche dass man
das alles machen darf das nützt doch
nicht demjenigen der schon immer
angemessen und vernünftig gewohnt hat
meine Damen und Herren und wem nützt es
das sechs Monate lang man sich vor
seinen Jobcenter Mitarbeiterin setzen
kann sie breit angrenzen kann sagen kann
ich habe keine Lust und es passiert
genau gar nichts das hilft nicht
denjenigen die arbeiten wollen das hilft
nur denjenigen die nicht arbeiten wollen
und deswegen ist ihr Bürgergeld keine
Reform des Sozialstaats sondern eine
Beleidigung des Sozialstaats
und wie simpel grün rot denkt das hat
der Frau Hasselmann gerade dargestellt
aber dass ich ausgerechnet der FDP mal
die Grundsätze des gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalts erklären müssen das hätte
ich mir nicht gedacht aber ich tue es
trotzdem unsere Gesellschaft basiert auf
einem ständigen Geben und Nehmen in
Wirtschaft in Handel in der Arbeit ja
man gibt Leistung man bekommt ein Gehalt
in der Schule man gibt Aufmerksamkeit
man bekommt Bildung nur im Bürgergeld da
gibt man gar nichts und dann bekommt
trotzdem meine Damen und Herren und man
bekommt sogar so viel dass ein
Niedriglohnempfänger fast schlechter
dasteht als ein bürgergeldempfänger und
da müssen wir uns doch nicht wundern
Frau Nase da müssen wir uns doch nicht
wundern dass Leute statt selber auf dem
Bau zu gehen lieber bei RTL2 anderen
beim Bauen zugucken nur davon hilft
davon profitiert unsere Wirtschaft nicht
wir haben fast eine Million offene
Stellen in niedrig und unqualifizierten
Bereich und sie reden von Qualifizierung
übrigens auch für diejenigen die sich
nie haben qualifizieren wollen und
wissen Sie was das schlimme ist
bitte im Bürgergeld helfen sie niemandem
der wirklich Hilfe braucht
sie verhöhnen diejenigen die jeden Tag
zur Arbeit gehen und sie stigmatisieren
diejenigen die wirklich nicht arbeiten
können denn in der öffentlichen
Wahrnehmung werden die doch in einen
Topf geworfen mit all den Chaos potatoes
die eben nicht nicht können sondern die
nicht wollen ein Sozialsystem muss
diejenigen schützen die Arbeiten
denjenigen helfen die es nicht können
und diejenigen motivieren die es nicht
wollen
Norbert Kleinwächter ist
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der
afd-fraktion und der Bundestag
diskutiert über das bürgergeldgesetz der
Koalition nächster Redner Johannes Vogel
ist erster parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer der FDP-Fraktion und hat
mal eine Bundesagentur Filiale in
Wuppertal Solingen geleitet
dem Kollegen Demokratie lebt
von wertargumente und die Opposition
soll deswegen natürlich die Koalition
kritisieren auch beim Bürgergeld nehmen
wir das Beispiel schon vermögen wir sind
der Meinung dass wenn zum Beispiel ein
selbstständiger durch einen
Schicksalsschlag auf die Grundsicherung
angewiesen ist dass er nicht als erstes
seine Altersvorsorge aufbrauchen soll
sie sehen das anders das ist ihr gutes
Recht darüber können wir hier streiten
es macht aber einen zentralen
Unterschied und das hat ist bei mir bei
dieser Debatte wirklich wichtig es macht
einen zentralen Unterschied ob man ein
alternatives politisches Urteil fällt
oder ob man alternative Fakten erfindet
und das haben wir hier in der
bürgerkette erlebt wir brauchen in der
Demokratie und das ist mir wirklich
ernst eine gemeinsame debattengrundlage
auf Basis von Fakten und
mir liegt hier der sitzungswöchentliche
Brief von Friedrich Merz aus der letzten
Sitzungswoche erste Lesung Bürgergeld
vor wo sich schwarz auf weiß Aussagen
finden die wir auch die letzten Tage
immer wieder in der Debatte gehört haben
mit dem Bürgergeld soll eine
sechs-monatige sanktionsfreie Karenzzeit
eingeführt werden sagen Sie Herr Merz
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
schlicht nicht wahr es stimmt nicht es
gibt keine sanktionsfreien Zeiten im
Bürgergeld sondern 80 Prozent der
Sanktionen werden auch den ersten sechs
Monaten weiter verhängt und danach sogar
das volle verfassungsrechtlich mögliche
Maße das ist kein Geheimnis Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Grünen hätten sich das
anders gewünscht das ist auch okay in
einer Demokratie aber wer etwas anderes
verbreitet der verbreitet Fake News und
das geht nicht in der demokratischen
Debatte
ein weiteres Zitat aus ihrem Brief die
Regelsätze sollen über die
Inflationsanpassung hinaus angehoben
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das ist schlicht nicht wahr es stimmt
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Union an der rechnungsmethode der
Regelsätze ändert sich nichts zu Recht
gleichen wir die Inflation nicht mehr
anderthalb Jahre später aus das auch
eine Frage der Fairness und ja es ist
bekannt manche Kollegen Kollegen aus
Koalitionsfraktionen von SPD und Grünen
hätten sich eine andere
Berechnungsmethode gewünscht aber das
steht nicht im Gesetzentwurf den wir
hier beraten und vollends schizophren
wird es wenn sie behaupten durch das
Bürgergeld lohne sich Arbeit in
Deutschland nicht mehr das ist erstens
in jedem einzelnen Fall falsch und
zweitens polymisieren sie damit gegen
eine Berechnungsmethode der Regelsätze
die eine CDU-Ministerin selber
eingeführt hat liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist doch schizophren und
unredlich
vollends
vollends verrückt wird es dann mit ihrem
move dieser Woche dass sie die Regel
ich nehme gerne eine Zwischenfrage
wollte ich gerade das wollte ich dir
gerade fragen also sie dürfen Herr
Kleinwächter
wertekollege Vogel sie haben gerade
kritisiert dass von der oppositionsseite
vorgetragen wird Arbeiten lohne sich
nicht mehr im bürgergeldbezug und dass
sie sagen es lohnt sich immer
sind wir uns einig dass sich lohnen
prinzipiell schon mal eine subjektive
Kategorie ist und sind wir uns zudem
einig dass wenn jemand ein Mindestlohn
verdient Vollzeit arbeitet da landet bei
1404 Euro netto Steuerklasse 1
dass der gerade wenn er in einer sehr
großen Wohnung wohnt mit sehr
umfangreichen Wohn- und Heizkosten plus
Regelbedarf im Endeffekt im
bürgergeldbezug fast auf das gleiche
kommt wie wenn er entsprechend dieses
Gehalt wird ja er hat den Zuverdienst ja
er hat den Selbstbehalt ja er hat die 20
30 Prozent je nach Stufe in Gera ist in
der im Endeffekt noch zu verdienen kann
aber bei den 200-300 Euro die es
rauskommt würden sie wirklich behaupten
dass es sich lohnt jeden Morgen
aufzustehen 40 Stunden die Wochen in die
Arbeit zu gehen eben nicht mehr die
Supermarkt Prospekte durchgehen zu
können für das günstigste essen sondern
auswärts essen gehen müssen ein
autoverhalten zu müssen und all das und
würden Sie nicht auch annehmen dass
durch Abzug all dieser
Opportunitätskosten faktisch für diese
Menschen bei Ihrem System ein Verlust
entsteht
frage ich gebe mir die Gelegenheit etwas
aufzuklären was in den letzten Tagen
auch in der Debatte irreführend war
richtig ist dass in unserem Sozialstaat
übrigens vorgegeben durch Rechtsprechung
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts die
Ansprüche auf das Existenzminimum zum
Beispiel bei großen Familien so hoch
sind dass ein allein verlieren mit
Mindestlohn das nicht alleine durch sein
Arbeitslohn erwirtschaftet das ist
richtig das ist Ausdruck auch des
sozialstaatsprinzips das gibt unsere
Verfassung vor das hat aber genau nichts
mit dem Bürgergeld zu tun weil das heute
schon so der Fall ist und auch
richtigerweise der Fall ist die Frage
ist also wie können wir dafür sorgen
dass sich Anstrengung zum Beispiel auch
bei diesen großen Familien wenn Menschen
arbeiten stärker lobt heute schon gibt
es keinen Fall wo der der arbeitet
weniger hat als der der nicht arbeitet
und das ist auch richtig durch
Kindergeld Kinder Rückschlag Wohngeld
all das was wir auch jetzt Anpassen an
die Inflation aber richtig ist es muss
sich stärker lohnen und dann muss man an
ein Thema ran was mir in der Tat sehr am
Herzen liegt nämlich das Thema
zuverdienstregeln und deshalb ist es
auch so absurd was die Union diese Woche
vorschlägt nämlich einfach nur die
Regelsätze zu erhöhen ohne durch die
Reform des Bürgergeldes auch für mehr
Leistungsgerechtigkeit und
Aufstiegschancen zu sorgen das müssen
wir doch tun liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es gibt es gibt eine weitere
Zwischenfrage von Herrn birkwald aus der
Fraktion DIE LINKE ich würde jetzt gerne
den Gedanken kurz zu Ende führen der
Kollege Matthias birkwald verzeiht mir
das gut
nein das ist die Wahrheit ich erinnere
mich gut an meine erste politische
Verhandlung als junger Abgeordneter in
der schwarz-gelben Koalition mit dem
cdu-kanzleramtsminister der CDU
Arbeitsministerin und ich habe mich
dafür eingesetzt dass die zuverdienste
reformiert werden sie ich habe mich
damals nicht durchsetzen können weil sie
Angst vor statistik-effekten hatten ich
habe das aber nicht vergessen weil wir
an diese Ungerechtigkeit unseres
Sozialstaats endlich ran müssen es muss
sich mehr lohnen Schritt für Schritt
rauszuwachsen aus der Grundsicherung und
das schaffen wir jetzt endlich das ist
Kern der Bürger der Reform liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und damit machen wir übrigens auch klar
dass junge Menschen diesem Land endlich
stärker Piloten des eigenen Lebens
werden heute lohnt sich nämlich auch
eine Ausbildung nicht das machen wir
anders das machen wir besser durchs
Bürgergeld heute werden zum Beispiel
wenn Annika die in einer
hartz-iv-familie groß wird im Minijob
arbeitet kann sie von 520 Euro 184
behalten wenn Eiche deren Eltern
finanziell auf eigenen Beinen stehen
denselben Minijob macht dann kann sie
520 Euro behalten junge Menschen
Verfahren schon in diesem Land heute vor
dem Bürgergeld am Anfang ihres Lebens
dass ich ihre Anstrengung nicht lohnt
das ist kein Unterschied macht wenn sie
arbeiten dass sie schlechtere Chancen
haben wegen weil ihre Eltern in
schwieriger Lagen sind das ist das
Gegenteil von Chancen Unabhängigkeit
unabhängig von der Herkunft und das
verbessern wir endlich
durch mehr Leistungsgerechtigkeit und
Aufstiegschancen
das macht nämlich vor allem was in den
Köpfen meine Fraktion hat diese Woche
drei junge Menschen nach Berlin
eingeladen Ferrat Sarah und Alex jeder
kann sich ihre Geschichten gerade seit
heute morgen auf Youtube anschauen sie
beschreiben sehr eindrücklich was das
was das in den Köpfen und den Herzen
macht wenn man schlechtere Chancen hat
wegen der Familie in die man geboren
wurde wir müssen uns doch nicht wundern
dass in unserem Land Chancen stärker von
der Herkunft abhängen wenn wir bereits
am Anfang des Lebens junge Menschen
Steine in den Weg legen das schaffen wir
endlich ab und darauf bin ich stolz denn
für diese Menschen kämpfen wir und
machen unser Sozialstaat fairer deshalb
stimmen wir heute für das Bürgergeld
vielen Dank
Johannes Vogel der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
FDP-Fraktion in der Debatte zum
bürgergeldgesetz
und da warten wir jetzt auf Dietmar
Bartsch dem Vorsitzenden der
Linksfraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
das was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
aktuell erleben das ist nicht anders zu
bezeichnen als ein Schmierentheater die
Wirtschaftsweisen haben angesichts der
Krise höhere Steuern für die
Topverdiener verlangt völlig zu Recht
und sie die Union lehnen das ab sie
spielen stattdessen Geringverdiener
gegen Arbeitslose aus das
Milliardenvermögen der Superreichen
schützen und das sogenannte
Schonvermögen von Menschen die
jahrzehntelang gearbeitet haben in Frage
stellen das ist unwürdig insbesondere
mit dem Blick auf das C in ihrem Namen
meine Damen und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Britta Hasselmann die Lebenswirklichkeit
die Lebenswirklichkeit ist dass die
Regelsätze jetzt 449 49 Euro betragen
ich erinnere daran dass im Januar die
Regelsätze um drei Euro erhöht worden
sind das war erbärmlich das war der
Staat der Koalition drei Euro so viel
kostet heute ein Stück Butter die
Inflation liegt bei zehn Prozent sie
hätten die Regelsätze schon im Sommer
mindestens um diese 53 Euro anheben
müssen jetzt laufen die Taschen übrig
Fortschritt Koalition in der Realität
ist das eine Schnarch Koalition immer zu
spät und immer zu wenig das ist die
Realität meine Damen und Herren bei den
Energiepreisen Deckelung viel zu spät
Erhöhung der Regelsätze Inflation
verpennt jetzt ist November sie mit
ihrer briesigkeit haben Friedrich Merz
erst ermöglicht dass es die Wahrheit
meine Damen und Herren
wir wir erkennen ganz klar an wir
erkennen ganz klar an es gibt
Fortschritte Hubertus Heil hat das an
einem Beispiel eindringlich geschildert
Schüler Azubis studierende können
deutlich mehr Fett behalten von ihren
Verdiensten dass es gut die zweijährige
Karenzzeit beim Wohnen sicherlich
positiv überhaupt keine Frage aber bei
allen Fortschritten bei allen
Fortschritten das Bürgergeld ist nicht
im
ansatzarmutsfest 53 Euro bleiben Armut
per Gesetz meine Damen und Herren
bedrückt sich man die Inflation sind das
0,0 meine Damen und Herren liebe
Sozialdemokraten und Sozialdemokraten
was steht in eurem Wahlprogramm die
Regelsätze im neuen Bürgergeld müssen zu
einem Leben in Würde ausreichen und zur
gesellschaftlichen Teilhabe befähigen
mit 53
also was für ein Käse und was steht noch
in eurem Wahlprogramm das Bürgergeld
muss absichern dass eine kaputte
Waschmaschine und eine neue Winterjacke
nicht zu untragbaren Last werden das
leistet das Bürgergeld ausdrücklich
nicht das Bürgergeld ist zu wenig für
würde und auch zu wenig für eine neue
Waschmaschine meine Damen und Herren
Bürgergeld sind gut aber real ist das
eben keine Abkehr von Hartz IV das
System bleibt erhalten in der Substanz
ist es Hartz 5 meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von denen
die meinen die Regelsätze dürfen nicht
armutsfest sein und das Schonvermögen
müsste möglichst gering sein da wird
immer dann das Lohnabstandsgebot
angeführt wie absurd ist das denn wir
haben kein Problem mit zu hohen
Regelsätzen wir haben aber einen
millionenfaches lohnproblem und das wird
dann zu einem Rentenproblem im Verkauf
einer Pflege bei den Dienstleistungen
sind die Löhne schlicht zu niedrig die
Löhne müssen auf und nicht die Leistung
politisch klein gerechnet werden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie immer auch
das Kind heißen mag am 1 Januar müssen
die Sätze steigen und wir brauchen
schleunigst dann eine realistische
Neuberechnung die den Mensch die die
Menschen wirklich tatsächlich vor Armut
schützen und ein Leben in Würde
garantiert und in der Zwischenzeit da
brauchen wir monatliche Zuschläge wie
das in unserem Antrag steht das wäre
eine Brücke meine Damen und Herren und
der Union kann ich nur zurufen hören sie
mit ihrer Blockade auf kein
Verschiebebahnhof zum ersten siebten die
Lage für die Betroffenen vielfach
dramatisch nehmen Sie bitte diese
Menschen in den Blick herzlichen Dank
geht man bereits Stefan der
Linksfraktion ihm wird jetzt folgen
Martin Rosemann der ist Arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitischer Sprecher der
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
das Bürgergeld ist die größte
Sozialreform seit 20 Jahren wir
überwinden damit Hartz 4 vor allem aber
ist das Bürgergeld die Antwort auf die
aktuellen Herausforderungen auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt für einen Arbeitsmarkt der
gekennzeichnet ist durch
Arbeitskräftemangel nicht mehr durch
Massenarbeitslosigkeit und deshalb
passen wir das System der Grundsicherung
an die Herausforderungen der Zeit an
sechs grundsätzliche Veränderungen sind
dabei wesentlich erstens mehr Respekt
für Lebensleistungen
Karenzzeit bei der Vermögensanrechnung
macht eben den Unterschied zwischen
denen die immer gearbeitet haben und
sich was angespart haben und denen die
das nicht gemacht haben und nach ihrer
Rede Herr Gröhe kann ich nur feststellen
wir die Ampel sind für mehr Respekt für
Lebensleistungen sie die Union sind
dagegen
zweitens
zweitens mehr Augenhöhe und damit einen
neuen Umgang zwischen dem Staat und den
Bürger denn es geht um individuelle und
passgenaue Unterstützung wir wollen den
Staat als Partner der denjenigen hilft
die Hilfe braucht drittens mehr
Zielgenauigkeit beim fordern allen
gegenteiligen Behauptungen zum Trotz das
neue Bürgergeld sieht
Mitwirkungspflichten vor und auch
Sanktionen für diejenigen die sich
verweigern aber wer von Beginn an
mitwirkt und das sind die meisten wird
in Zukunft eben nicht mehr mit
Sanktionen bedroht und wer nicht
mitwirken kann beispielsweise wegen
einer psychischen Erkrankung der muss
unterstützt und nicht sanktioniert
werden
viertens
mehr fördern mit dem neuen Instrument
des umfassenden Coachings der
Entfristung des sozialen Arbeitsmarkts
der aufsuchenden Arbeit dem
Weiterbildungsgeld und dem
bürgergeldbonus sorgen wir für bessere
individuelle und passgenaue
Unterstützung 5 mehr Nachhaltigkeit wir
schaffen den vermittlungsvorgang ab und
setzen auf passgenaue und nachhaltige
Vermittlung in gute Arbeit wenn wir
Menschen einfach nur schnell in Arbeit
bringen wollen riskieren wir nämlich
dass die Arbeit auch genauso schnell
wieder abgebrochen wird deshalb setzen
wir auf zielgenaue Qualifizierung in
gute Arbeit
und
und schließlich sechstens mehr
Leistungsgerechtigkeit denn wir erhöhen
die Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten vor allem
für junge Leute die selbst die Erfahrung
machen sollen dass sich arbeiten lohnt
mit dem neuen Bürgergeld gilt nun erst
recht das Arbeit den Unterschied macht
um
um all dies um all dies zu realisieren
entlasten wir die Jobcenter von
Bürokratie und wir werden den Haushalt
für die Jobcenter auch ausreichend
ausstatten aber
Haushaltsdebatte Liebe Hermann Gröhe ist
nächste Woche nicht diese Woche und in
diesem Zusammenhang weiß ich nur mal
darauf hin dass ich zu der Liste der
Fake News nun noch hinzugefügt hat wir
hätten den Bundesrechnungshof nicht
gehört gestern im Ausschuss für Arbeit
und Soziales über eine Stunde
Bundesrechnungshof Liebe Hermann Gröhe
meine
Damen und Herren Herr Rosemann gestatten
sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion ja bitte
lieber Herr Kollege Rosemann ihre
Kollegin Saskia esken und sie haben es
jetzt gerade auch selbst in ihrer Rede
bestätigt hat heute morgen gesagt wir
müssen nicht mehr so viel fordern weil
wir befinden uns ja an einer
vollbeschäftigungsphase erkennen Sie an
dass das Prinzip aus Fordern und Fördern
der letzten nahezu 20 Jahre zu einem
großartigen Erfolg auf unserem
Arbeitsmarkt geführt wurde die Zahl der
Arbeitslosen deutlich reduziert werden
konnte und weitere Frage was passiert
eigentlich wenn sie jetzt nicht mehr
fordern sondern nur noch fördern stellen
Sie sich darauf ein dass wir künftig
wieder mehr Arbeitslose haben vielen
Dank
ja Frau Schimke vielen Dank für die
Frage
erstens frage ich mich so bisschen was
mit ihren Ohren los ist denn sie haben
offensichtlich immer noch nicht
verstanden dass wir fördern und fördern
nicht abschaffen dass es weiterhin
Mitwirkungspflichten und Sanktionen gibt
und Fake News Entschuldigung werden
durch Wiederholung nicht wahrer Frau
Schimke zweitens
zweitens
zweitens ich finde es interessant ich
finde es interessant dass sie mit diesem
Redebeitrag noch mal deutlich gemacht
haben dass die Union die Debatten von
vor 20 Jahren führt während wir die
Debatten von heute und für morgen führen
nehmen Sie doch zur Kenntnis dass wir es
mit einer anderen Situation auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt zu tun haben und drittens
und drittens Frau Schimke ich bin für
Fördern und Fordern und ich bin auch
dafür dass ich Leute die sich diesen
Mitwirkungspflichten entziehen entziehen
obwohl sie mitwirken können dass die
auch mit den Konsequenzen zu rechnen
haben im Rahmen dessen was das
Bundesverfassungsgericht vorgibt genauso
steht es im Gesetz aber was ich Ihnen
auch sagen will es müssten sie
eigentlich wissen mit ihrem beruflichen
Hintergrund als Vertreterin der
Arbeitgeberverbände müssten sie doch
wissen dass kein Arbeitgeber jemanden
einstellt der sich nur deshalb bei ihm
bewirbt weil ihm sonst Sanktionen drohen
es muss doch ein Mindestmaß an
Motivation geben und dafür müssen wir
sorgen
meine Damen und Herren ich danke den
Beschäftigten in den Jobcentern schon
heute für die Umsetzung dieser Reform
wir wissen dass das eine Herausforderung
darstellt aber wir bekommen viel
Zustimmung für diese Reform aus der
Praxis und weil hier schon wieder der
Brandbrief beschrieben wird ich habe den
Brandbrief gelesen der Vorsitzende der
personalrätevertreter wohnt in meinem
Wahlkreis ich bin mit dem im Austausch
und ich lese seine Nachrichten auf
Twitter und ich kann Ihnen sagen dass
wir das in Kraft treten der einzelnen
Punkte des Gesetzes genau so regeln wie
die Personalräte der Jobcenter des
verlangt haben
wir haben uns
wir haben uns entschieden im übrigen
diese große Reform des Bürgergeldes auf
zwei Gesetze aufzuteilen um die
Jobcenter nicht zu überfordern deswegen
werden wir auch den zuführdienst nochmal
umfassend Regeln den sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt weiterentwickeln und auch
andere Instrumente weiterentwickeln mit
einem zweiten Paket jetzt geht es aber
um das erste Paket und die Ampel hat
umfangreiche Änderungen am Gesetz
vorgenommen und geht dabei auch auf
Forderungen und Kritikpunkte aus dem
Bundesrat ein
wir stellen zum Beispiel klar dass die
vertrauenszeit erst zustande kommt wenn
ein kooperationsplan gemeinsam
erarbeitet wurde wir sorgen dafür dass
bereits genutzte Karenzzeiten
angerechnet werden wir sorgen dafür dass
in der Karenzzeit lediglich angemessene
Heizkosten übernommen werden und Umzüge
in teurere Wohnungen der Genehmigung
bedürfen nun hat es der Bundesrat haben
es die Länder in der Hand sich auch
ihrer Verantwortung zu stellen es liegt
jetzt an Ihnen ob zum ersten Januar die
dringend erforderliche Anhebung der
Regelsätze stattfindet ich fordere Sie
auf nehmen Sie diese Verantwortung wahr
Martin Rosemann für die SPD-Fraktion in
der Debatte zum bürgergeldgesetz Morgen
ist der 11.11 am 11.11 vor vier Jahren
hat die damalige SPD-Vorsitzende Andrea
Nahles beim debattenkämpft der SPD zum
ersten Mal in einer großen öffentlichen
Rede angekündigt dass die SPD Hartz IV
überwinden wolle das ist eine
sozialstaatsreform geben müssen also
endet heute ein vier Jahre dauernder
Prozess bis hin zum Bürgergeld vom Hartz
IV von ALG2 zum Bürgergeld Stefan
Stracke istanbold Arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitischer Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion hier ist unsere
ausgestreckte Hand als Fraktion meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren und ich
fordere Sie auf nehmen Sie diese
ausgestreckte Hand zeigen sie
Verantwortung und sorgen Sie für
Sicherheit für diejenigen die das
tatsächlich ernsthaft gebrauchen und
benötigen und ich habe den Eindruck sie
wollen nicht Sicherheit und
Verlässlichkeit geben sondern sie wollen
dass als Faustpfand behalten für die
Durchsetzung ihres vermorgsten
Bürgergeld Gesetzes in diesem Werk und
das ist das Gegenteil von Verantwortung
Herr Minister
wir befürworten eine schnellere
Anpassung der Regelsätze an die
Teuerungsrate und gleichwohl bleibt
richtig Arbeit muss sich lohnen und das
sagen sie ja selber auch wir wollen das
Arbeit sich lohnt das Arbeit den
Unterschied macht und dann wenn man sich
die Vielzahl an Berechnungen da auch mal
anschaut dann zeigt sich in gewissen
Fallkonstellationen nicht die Arbeit
macht den Unterschied sondern die
ergänzende Sozialleistung macht den
Unterschied nämlich das Wohngeld oder
der Kinderzuschlag und wenn wir darauf
hinweisen dass hier Handlungsbedarf
besteht dann werden wir von ihnen
beschimpft wenn wir darauf hinweisen
dass wir das Steuerrecht an dieser
Stelle verändern müssen dann werden wir
von ihnen beschimpft allerdings ihr
eigener Kollege auf der Regierungsbank
Herr heilt nicht der
Bundesfinanzminister sagt zitiere ich
darf zitieren
der Funken Mediengruppe in den Zeitungen
von 29.10 Zitat von Christian Lindner
wenn Sozialleistungen wie der Regelsatz
bei der Grundsicherung automatisch an
die Inflation angepasst werden dann
müssen auch die arbeitenden Menschen
einen automatischen Ausgleich bekommen
recht hat er aber das ist nichts was zu
diffamieren gilt und deswegen bedarf ist
natürlich auch hier eines
veränderungsbedarfes an dieser Stelle
und
was wird denn jetzt besser erlauben sie
eine weitere Zwischenfrage oder
Bemerkungen aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
Tage
warum Herr starker meinen sie haben die
Vorsitzende von CSU und CDU Herr Söder
und der März nicht der Versuchung
widerstehen können und sind zu erzählen
es ist Unsinn zu behaupten dass ich
Arbeit nicht lohnt weil sich Arbeit
immer rechnet im Vergleich es ist Unsinn
Äpfel und Birnen vergleichen zu wollen
indem man so tut als würde bei den Hartz
IV beziehenden bzw Bürgergeld
beziehenden alles was an sozialen
Transfers möglich ist in Anspruch
genommen und den zum Vergleich
herangezogenen Niedriglöhner da
unterstellt man dass er das gerade nicht
tut das ist Unsinn es ist Unsinn so zu
tun
als gäbe es im Bürgergeld keine
Mitwirkungspflichten das Gegenteil ist
der Fall und zwar sowohl nach
vertrauenszeit als auch in der
kooperationszeit warum meinen sie haben
ihre Vorsitzenden darauf gesetzt Fake
News in die Welt zu setzen und den
Menschen nichts von U vortragen zu
wollen was ist da los bei Ihnen
den herzlichen Dank Herr Kollege ich
glaube das gibt auch noch mal
Gelegenheit darauf einzugehen zum einen
machen wir es mal ganz ohne
streitstellen immer einfach mal ein
Beispiel dass der DGB gerechnet hat das
entspricht ja auch ihre linken Seele
etwas mehr bei einem Paar von zwei
Kindern 8 und 12 Jahre alt ein Verdienst
von 38 Stunden Mindestlohn von 12 Euro
der Vergleich der DGB sie können das
alles nachlesen alles ganz transparent
auf der dgb-seite Vergleich des mit
einem bürgergeldbezieher und es
verfügbare Einkommen bei den
bürgergeldbezieher im vergleichbarer
Situation liegt bei 2.349 Euro bei
demjenigen der arbeitet bei
2050 Euro also
299 Euro weniger in der Tasche als ein
Hartz-IV-Empfänger
und wenn wir darauf hinweisen erst durch
die ergänzende Sozialleistung nämlich
das Wohngeld und den Kinderzuschlag in
Höhe von 817 Euro so wie es der DGB
eröffnet hat und berechnet hat das macht
dann das Plus von 500 Euro dann
unterstellen sie uns da und beschimpfen
wir uns in dem Fall weil eben nicht die
Arbeit den Unterschied macht sondern die
ergänzende Sozialleistung und das ist ja
auch der Grund warum der
Bundesarbeitsminister darauf hinweist
dass er das Kindergeld erhöht den
Kinderzuschlag erhöht der
Grundfreibetrag erhöht wird und vieles
mehr also das ist der Unterschied und
ein zweites weil sie das Thema
Sanktionen angesprochen haben auch hier
sie bleiben mit dem Bürgergeld Entwurf
weit hinter dem zurück was das
Bundesverfassungsgericht zulässt und sie
bleiben auch hinter dem zurück was
bislang Praxis des der
Bundesarbeitsagentur war ich will Ihnen
an dieser Stelle mal ein paar Beispiel
nennen beim den ersten halben Jahr
können Sie jegliche der sie müssen noch
stehen bleiben ich beantworte Ihre Frage
mit den Sanktionen würden Sie bitte
stehen bleiben beantwortet immer noch
die ihre Frage weil sie sagen was das
Thema Sanktionen angeht im ersten halben
Jahr im ersten halben Jahr können Sie
jegliches Vermittlungsangebot jeglichen
Deutschkurs jeglichen Integrationskurs
jegliche
Weiterbildungsmöglichkeit folgenlos
abbrechen oder nicht antreten das ist
ihre Politik hier atmet diese
Grundsicherung letztendlich den Geist
des bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen und
ein meldeversäumnis ja das ist im ersten
halben Jahr möglich zu sanktionieren
aber erst nach zweiten meldeversonnen
sie haben einen freischuß in dem Bereich
eingeführt und auch bei den
Pflichtverletzungen im übrigen bleiben
sie auch hier weil ich immer noch bei
den Sanktionen bin bei
Pflichtverletzungen ich will nur darauf
bleiben sie in Not dabei 20 Prozent
bleiben sie weit hinweg und auch was die
total Verweigerer angeht das
bundesfassungsgericht hat gesagt
derjenige der sich beharrlich verweigert
der muss und kann auch total
sanktioniert werden davon machen Sie
keine Möglichkeit also von dem Anspruch
das was das bundesfassungsgericht an
Möglichkeiten eröffnet machen sie
weniger und damit ist es ein weniger am
fordern in diesem Bereich was das
Geld
tatsächlich macht Herr Stracke ich habe
auch wenn der Tag heute insgesamt lang
wird aber ich habe noch eine
Zwischenfrage oder Zwischenbemerkung aus
der SPD-Fraktion
ich freue mich ja
Herr Kollege Stracke ich würde gerne
darauf eingehen was sie in den letzten
Wochen vorgetragen haben zu der Frage ob
sich Arbeit lohnt und was sie heute
vorgetragen haben das ist nämlich sehr
interessant sie räumen ja immerhin ein
dass viele der Berechnungen die
Sozialleistungen ergänzenden oder auch
aufstockenem Sozialleistungen missachtet
haben und deswegen zu interessanten
Ergebnissen gekommen sind um es mal
vorsichtig zu sagen was aber jetzt meine
Frage ist wenn Sie erkannt haben dass
nicht die Arbeit alleine und der
Arbeitslohn alleine ohne ergänzende
Sozialleistungen den Unterschied macht
wenn Sie das erkannt haben warum haben
Sie sich denn eine Erhöhung des
Mindestlohns auf 12 Euro verweigert und
warum Frau weigern sie sich auch einer
Erhöhung der Tarifbindung
wissen sie
das Thema Mindestlohn ist eine Debatte
wo wir dann auf achten müssen wie wir
das richtig machen gerade was die
Erhöhung auf des Mindestlohns in diesem
Bereichen ist das aber es ist ja
interessant dass sie ausschließlich als
Antwort dann finden dass wir arbeiten
immer teurer machen müssen gerade auch
in anderen Bereichen und damit weniger
Einstiegschancen in diesem Bereich und
deswegen ist es ja so richtig wenn der
Bundesfinanzminister eine anderen
Vorschlag unterbreitet nämlich dem
Bereich der Grundfreibeträge
entsprechend anzuheben und wenn wir
darauf hinweisen dass das genau der
richtige Ansatzpunkt ist in diesem
Bereich und nicht neue Barrieren
entstehen zu lassen dann werden wir von
ihnen beschimpft und das zeigt doch wie
heuchlerisch Sie unterwegs sind weil auf
ihrer eigenen Regierungsbank sie zur
anderen Lösungen kommen in diesen
Bereich und wenn wir darauf hinweisen
dass das genau die richtige Lösung ist
dann tun sie das nicht meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und was wird
denn jetzt tatsächlich besser durch das
durch das sie können gerne noch stehen
bleiben was wird denn besser durch das
Bürgergeld diese Frage stellt sich
beispielsweise die FDP in einem
inflationsinformationspapier der
Fraktion ich frage mich das auch was
eigentlich durch das Bürgergeld besser
wird aber interessant ist die Antwort
aus der Hängematte wird ein Sprungbrett
das muss man sich erst einmal auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen
auf aus der Hängematte wird ein Sprung
Weg sie
diffamigen die in einer sozialen Notlage
sich befinden
als ihr Mathe meine sehr verehrten Damen
ungeheuerlicher
[Applaus]
vorkommen ist in unsere triumphzeit
geschafft sich herauszuarbeiten aus
Arbeitslosigkeit und einen festen
Arbeitsplatz in der Arbeitsgesellschaft
erreicht über 2 Millionen Menschen haben
Hartz IV als Sprungbrett benutzt und um
zurückzukommen in Arbeit das ist das
Gegenteil von einer Hängematte sie
diffamieren hier dieses System sie
diffamieren die Menschen in diesem
Bereich der eine großartige Leistung
erbracht haben das ist Respektlosigkeit
und da sieht man mal welchen Geist hier
in diesem Haus bei der Ampel tatsächlich
vorhanden ist und es ist auch respektlos
im übrigen gegenüber den Mitarbeitern in
den Jobcentern die tatkräftig hierbei
unterstützen dass diese Erfolg gelungen
ist und jetzt zu ihrem das was sie sich
rühmen nämlich die Veränderung der
Hinzuverdienstgrenzen
und die Verbesserungen dabei ich wundere
mich ja wenn man sagt naja wer eine AR
derjenige der einen Azubi-Gehalt bekommt
der hat jetzt mehr davon als vorher das
ist richtig aber warum machen Sie denn
hier eine Grenze von 25 Jahren warum ist
denn derjenige der im Alter der
vielleicht eine Familie hat der sich
entscheiden muss geht er denn in
Ausbildung oder macht er denn
beispielsweise ein Aushilfsjob dass sie
da gerade nicht diese Verbesserungen für
diejenigen machen oder ein zweites sie
rühmen sich der Tatsache dass sie jetzt
zehn Cent mehr von einem verdienten Euro
in der Tasche haben nämlich die
Beziehung da sagt zu Recht das Institut
der deutschen Wirtschaft das ist zu
wenig ambitioniert das ist zu wenig
ambitioniert das ist kein Anreiz eine
Tätigkeit mit einem Entlohnung über 1200
Euro letztendlich aufzunehmen das was
sie als Sprungbrett definieren damit
machen Leistungsbezieher tatsächlich
keine großen Sprünge wir brauchen
weniger aufstiegslyrik sondern
wirklichen Aufstieg für die Menschen
dafür sorgen Sie mit diesem Bürgergeld
nicht
Stefan Stracke war das Arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitischer Sprecher der CDU
CSU-Fraktion in einer Debatte über das
bürgergeldgesetz der auch drei Anträge
aus der Linksfraktion zugrunde liegen
und eine aus der afd-fraktion und wir
stellen fest quer durch die Reihen es
geht hier heute nicht ohne Polemik in
dieser Debatte die nächste Rednerin
Werte sein Stefanie Effner aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen sie ist
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Arbeit und
Soziales und in diesem Ausschuss
speziell zuständig für das Thema
Bürgergeld
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen wir führen hier eine
hochemotionale Debatte es wird Arroganz
vorgeworfen es werden Berechnungen in
den Raum geworfen die hinterher wieder
korrigiert werden müssen ich
entschuldige mich bei all den Menschen
in diesem Land die davon betroffen sind
denn die Debatte wird auf ihrem Rücken
ausgetragen über wen reden wir denn an
dieser Stelle
über 60 Prozent der Menschen die
arbeitslos werden finden innerhalb von
einem Jahr wieder einen Job die kommen
also gar nicht in den bürgergeldbezug
weitere 20 Prozent der Menschen haben
nach zwei Jahren einen Job und hier
kommt jetzt der erste Konflikt mit der
Union wir sagen wir wollen zwei Jahre
Karenzzeit dass Menschen zwei Jahre ihre
Wohnung behalten können sie haben einen
Positionspapier von ihrer AG die es auf
ein Jahr begrenzt fragen wir uns doch
mal für welche Menschen macht das im
Endeffekt einen Unterschied
200.000 Menschen die wohlgemerkt an dem
Ende der von uns vorgeschlagenen
Karenzzeit wieder einen Job gefunden
haben den sie sagen wollen nein ihr
müsst umziehen und eure Wohnung auch
noch aufgeben obwohl ihr am Ende dieser
zwei Jahre wieder eine wohl eine Arbeit
haben werden das ist eine Stadt so groß
wie pot
die gleiche Debatte führen wir beim
Schonvermögen sie malen Bilder von
Menschen die in unheimlichen Reichtum
sich darin gefallen Bürgergeld zu
beziehen die zeittitelt heute Stütze für
reicher wie sieht denn die Realität aus
über 40 Prozent der Menschen in diesem
Land haben überhaupt keine Rücklagen
aber um wen geht es denn dann in dieser
Debatte es geht um die Menschen die zum
Beispiel eine Abfindung bekommen weil
sie arbeitslos werden es geht um die
Menschen die jahrzehntelang gearbeitet
haben und sich Rücklagen gebildet haben
und denen sagen wir schön dass ihr das
alles getan habt aber im übrigen die
gleiche Vermögensgrenze die sie in der
Pandemie selber eingeführt haben und die
auch im Wohngeld gilt das ist zu viel
und auch die Entlastung der Jobcenter
worum es nämlich auch geht der
Mitarbeitenden dass sie nicht mit
Demokratie beschäftigt sind an dieser
Stelle auch das lehnen sie ab
wir haben ein Sanktionen natürlich
weiterhin welche drin wir hätten davon
eine andere Vorstellung gehabt aber es
geht doch darum wie gehen wir mit der
übergroßen Mehrheit der Menschen im
bürgergeldbezug um sie schauen immer auf
die wenigen wo es Probleme gibt wir
sagen die allermeisten Menschen nämlich
97 Prozent wirken mit und arbeiten an
der Überwindung ihrer Situation und
genau die wollen wir nicht mehr
anlasslos bedrohen denn wir haben
Respekt vor diesen Menschen und das ist
unsere Aufgabe
Stefanie Effner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen ich kann noch mal einen
Punkt aufnehmen den Bärbel Bars die
Bundestagspräsidentin vorhin mal
Nebensatz gesagt hat der Tag wird lang
Erzieher gesagt und sich damit bezogen
auf die Tagesordnung die heutige des
Deutschen Bundestages die ging vor
dieser Debatte ohnehin schon bis 2:59
Uhr also bis 3 Uhr in der Nacht da wird
sicherlich einiges zu Protokoll gegeben
aber den Abgeordneten steht hier noch
einiges ans an Arbeit ins Haus heute
gerritory aus der afd-fraktion am Montag
haben wir von vielen Sachverständigen in
großer Deutlichkeit gehört dass das
Bürgergeld voraussichtlich noch mehr
Probleme aufweisen wird als heute schon
Hartz IV
und auch die Kritik des
Bundesrechnungshofs wird dadurch sehr
stark bestätigt der vor Ort Prüfung
durchgeführt hat und deswegen sehr gut
beurteilen kann was in den Jobcentern
funktioniert und was eben nicht und er
hat herausgefunden dass drei von vier
Jobcenter mit der Verwässerung und
Aufweichung der Sanktionsmöglichkeiten
große Probleme haben ich möchte mich
aber heute auf einen anderen neuen Punkt
konzentrieren nämlich den Entfall das
vermittlungsvorgangs dadurch erhofft
sich die ampelregierung dass eine
zusätzliche Qualifikation von
Langzeitarbeitslosen möglich wird und
damit eine bessere und nachhaltigere
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt ich
befürchte allerdings dass mit dieser
Maßnahme eher das Gegenteil erreicht
wird und wir stattdessen zusätzlich
Arbeitskräfte verlieren
Ausbildung und Weiterbildung waren
nämlich auch bisher schon möglich wurden
aber gerade von
Geringqualifizierten nur sehr selten
wahrgenommen und beim überwiegenden Teil
der Langzeitarbeitslosen handelt es sich
nur mal um Geringqualifizierte zwei
Drittel von ihnen verfügen über keinen
Berufsabschluss viele von ihnen haben
auch keinen Schulabschluss und es gibt
nach wie vor viele funktionale
Analphabeten unter ihnen da wird
Ausbildung und Weiterbildung extrem
schwierig
über die Hälfte der Langzeitarbeitslosen
sind Flüchtlinge eine weitere große
Gruppe hat einen Migrationshintergrund
häufig treten deshalb zu den allgemeinen
Lernschwierigkeiten auch noch
Sprachschwierigkeiten hinzu wir haben es
hier also mit einem fulminanten kaum zu
lösende Problem zu tun
meine Damen und Herren die
Nachqualifizierung wird nach allem was
wir in Erfahrung bringen konnten nur in
wenigen Fällen wohl funktionieren häufig
werden sich nicht genügend Teilnehmer
für eine Bildungsmaßnahme befinden und
die die mitmachen hören sehr häufig sehr
schnell wieder auf das ist für alle
Seiten extrem frustrierend wenn es auch
aus Seiten der Langzeitarbeitslosen mit
einem zusätzlichen Bildungsgeld wann
immerhin 150 Euro im Monat versüßt
werden soll
sie hören es nicht gerne aber Hartz IV
ist inzwischen unbeachtet der Tatsache
dass wir natürlich auch viele deutsche
Langzeitarbeitslose haben aber Hartz IV
und damit auch zukünftiges Bürgergeld
ist in großem Teilen inzwischen zu einem
Migrationsproblem geworden
kommen
halten qualifiz
ierte und viele von diesen geringen
qualifizierten wären für
helferpositionen vermutlich durchaus
geeignet es gibt aber uns viele
Migranten die in anderen Jobs tätig sind
aber aus Hartz IV heraus funktioniert
das anscheinend gar nicht mehr das
konnten wir im Sommer sehr deutlich
beobachten als für die
koffertransporteure an den Flughafen
eigens neue Migranten eingeführt werden
sollten
offensichtlich gilt gerade für
Zuwanderer aus sehr armen Ländern dass
sie sich recht auskömmlichen unseren
Sozialsystemen bewegen können Liebe
ampelkollegen
sie sollten sich deswegen nichts
vormachen ihre große und sicherlich gut
gemeinte Qualifizierungsoffensive wird
kaum den gewünschten Erfolg haben und
deswegen spreche ich es nochmal aus das
Problem an der Wurzel zu packen bedeutet
die unkontrollierte Einwanderung zu
stoppen
[Applaus]
Herr Probleme nicht Herr werden können
dankeschön
Gary Tool war das aus der afd-fraktion
ihr wird jetzt folgen Jens teutriner aus
der FDP-Fraktion er ist passenderweise
Sprecher für Bürgergeld
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen im Zentrum des
Bürgergeld steht es nicht wie immer
wieder behauptet wird mehr Lässigkeit im
Zentrum des Bürgergelds steht das
Leistungsprinzip um
Berufseinstiegschancen durch
Qualifizierung also die nachhaltige
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt das ist
das Zentrum des Bürgergeist und wenn man
ein Beispiel nennen müsste ein einziges
Beispiel an dem man das festmacht dann
sind es Auszubildende die in einer
hartz-iv-bedarfsgemeinschaft aufwachsen
wenn die aktuell dort 800 Euro
Ausbildungsvergütung haben dann bleiben
in faktisch nur 240 Euro der Rest wird
angerechnet das Hartz-IV-System was sie
verteidigen was sie nicht verändert
haben sagt diesen jungen Menschen eine
Ausbildung und Arbeit lohnt sich nicht
jetzt ist es so beim Bürgergeld von 800
Euro dürfen die 600 4 € behalten das ist
mehr als das 2,5-facher die Botschaft
des Sozialstaates ist klar es lohnt sich
zu arbeiten es lohnt sich eine
Ausbildung und wenn sie jetzt
kritisieren wie kann das denn sein dass
er überhaupt noch was angerechnet wird
das ist alles nur Aufstiegs Lyrik nein
das verändert bei jungen Menschen etwas
im Kopf es verändert die Botschaft und
wenn sie sagen wieso ist das zu wenig
wieso haben sie es in den letzten Jahren
nie angepasst wenn das doch eigentlich
eine Selbstverständlichkeit war weil es
ihn nicht um diese jungen Menschen geht
sondern es geht um eine Scheindebatte
und die Scheindebatte Herr Gröhe haben
wir erlebt sie haben gerade eben wieder
vorgeworfen den Brandbrief der
Personalräte der Brand lief der
Personalräte kam zum ersten
Gesetzesentwurf wir haben den
Gesetzesentwurf angepasst das so dass
beim zum ersten ersten nur die
Regelsätze in Kraft treten die
Karenzzeit und die Bagatellgrenze auf
Wunsch der BA die BA wünscht sich dass
diese Punkte zum ersten ersten Kraft
tritt alles andere wird nach hinten
verschoben die BA hat in der Anhörung
gesagt sie findet das total gut dass das
stattfindet sie hat gesagt sie braucht
diese Vorbereitungszeit und wünsche euch
dass der Bundesrat schnell zu einer
Entscheidung kommt weil eine Bugatti in
schaden würde ihr Kollege Stracke ist
dann zur Presse gegangen hat gesagt die
BA würde dem Vorschlag der CDU
unterstützen nur die Regelsätze zu
erhöhen und sie wiederholen das jetzt
gerade sogar noch in der Debatte das
sind das ist die Form von Fake News die
sie immer wieder vortragen
und jeder dieser Fake News zu entkräften
dauert länger als in die Welt setzen und
deswegen möchte ich noch einen zweiten
Punkt bringen wo sie ja vielleicht jetzt
mal auch in der Sache was kritisieren
sie kritisieren das schon Vermögen das
sei viel zu viel
unser Ansicht nach ist wer kurzfristig
ins SGB 2 rein rutscht weil er
beispielsweise gar kein Anspruch auf
Arbeitslosengeld 1 hat selbstständiger
als Beispiel der sollte nicht sofort
sein Haus verkaufen müssen seine
Altersvorsorge aufbrauchen müssen und
sein Erspartes dann sagt der Kollege
Whittaker genau dann sagt der Kollege
witteka ist doch jetzt schon das
Altersvorsorge ausgenommen wird ist doch
jetzt schon der Fall ich sehr auch
nicken in ihrem rein gerade guckt man
aber genau ins Gesetz ist das nur die
staatlich geförderte Altersvorsorge es
ist nur Riester und rührup sobald sich
jemand entscheidet privat vorzusagen
vorvorzusorgen ist die nicht ausgenommen
und genau diese Feinheiten lassen sie
jedes Mal bei jedem Argument weg und
schüren damit eine Debatte die es wo es
nicht um die Sache geht lassen Sie uns
um die Sache diskutieren wir sind für
private Altersvorsorge bei
Selbstständigen wir sind dafür dass sie
auch in Aktien investieren können und
das auch geschützt wird wenn Sie
kurzfristig reinkommen langfristig ist
es nicht möglich mit solchen
Vermögenswerten Bürgergeld zu beziehen
langfristig ist das nicht möglich das
verschweigen sie auch jedes Mal wenn es
um die Frage der Karenzzeit geht und
guckt man in ihrem Positionspapier der
cdu-arbeitsgruppe Arbeit und Soziales in
der Bundestagsfraktion noch wohl nicht
beschlossen worden super ist sogar
beschlossen worden da fordern sie selbst
diese schonvermögensgrenze dauerhaft das
ist sogar möglich mehr zu haben an schon
vor mögen als bei uns in verschiedenen
Fallbeispielen und deswegen ist die
Debatte nicht ehrlich sie wird nicht in
der Sache geführt sie wird unehrlich
geführt und deswegen es ist richtig dass
wir das Bürgergeld jetzt einführen und
ich würde mich freuen wir würden mehr in
der Sache diskutieren als mit falschen
Behauptungen ich freue mich dass sie
jetzt zum Glück jetzt auch mal langsam
die richtigen Berechnungen nehmen und
nicht mehr die der Jungen Freiheit weil
die waren lange genug auf der Seite der
CSU
Sprecher für Bürgergeld in der
FDP-Fraktion und hat verwiesen auf
Widersprüche zwischen Reben und
Positionspapieren der Unionsfraktion in
dieser Debatte es gibt ja hier schon
seit geraumer Zeit gegenseitige vorhalte
das mit falschen Zahlen agiert und
diskutiert werde Annika Klose ist die
nächste Rednerin aus der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
skandalskandal das neue Bürgergeld soll
kommen doch kann es sein liebe
Kolleginnen von der Union dass das
Gespenst was sie zu sehen glauben in
Wahrheit nur ein Schattenbild an einer
Höhlenwand ist ich möchte etwas zur
Erhellung beitragen erstens
was ist mit dem Skandal der angeblich zu
hohen Schonvermögen mit dem Bürgergeld
wollen wir dafür sorgen dass Menschen
die lange gearbeitet haben nicht direkt
auch noch ihre Rücklagen und ihre
Wohnung verlieren müssen wenn sie gerade
auch schon ihren Job verloren haben
sondern wir schaffen
der geschontfrist um sich weiter zu
alifizieren zu finden bevor die
Ersparnisse aufgebraucht werden ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich kann den Skandal nicht
erkennen vor allem nicht wenn wir von
Menschen erwarten dass sie bis 67
arbeiten sollen dann muss es das auch
mal möglich sein um zu schulen ohne
direkt alles zu verlieren
was ist mit
den olangen Karenzzeiten in den ersten
zwei Jahren sollen die Jobcenter noch
nicht alles bis ins Detail durchleuchten
und prüfen dass das schließlich ein
wahnsinniger wahnsinniger bürokratischer
Aufwand dabei kommen doch über 50% der
leistungsbezieherinnen und
Leistungsbezieher in den ersten zwei
Jahren auch wieder in Arbeit deswegen
sagen wir die Jobcenter sollen die
Wohnung und die privaten rücklehrlagen
erst nach dieser Schonfrist ganz genau
überprüfen das erleichtert nämlich allen
Beteiligten das Leben und schafft auch
leichtere Zukunft Zugänge in der
Krisenzeit auch hier ist der Skandal
ehrlich gesagt nicht zu erkennen und vor
zwei Jahren hat die Union da übrigens
auch noch zugestimmt und das genauso
gesehen
drittens Skandal wir wollen mehr
Menschen fördern statt nur zur fordern
wir schaffen mit dem Bürgergeld neue
Leistungen und Menschen die arbeitslos
sind besser bei der Arbeitsaufnahme zu
unterstützen denn es gibt
hunderttausende in diesem Land die trotz
der guten Lage auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
nicht vermittelt werden können klar klar
man kann natürlich auch alles so lassen
wie es ist und immer wieder dasselbe
versuchen und dann erwarten das
natürlich ein anderes Ergebnis dabei
rauskommt aber das hält ehrlich gesagt
nicht nur Albert Einstein für Wahnsinn
also erweitern wir mal den
Instrumentenkasten der Jobcenter und
ehrlich gesagt kann ich hier den Skandal
ebenfalls nicht erkennen ich freue mich
ja wirklich dass die Union mittlerweile
erkannt hat dass die Erhebung der
Anhebung der Regelsetzung 50 Euro kein
Skandal ist sondern bitter nötig aber
jetzt nur das zu machen und alles andere
zu lassen ist halt leider auch deutlich
zu kurz gesprungen und da ich jetzt mal
vermute dass sie das mir nicht glauben
werden möchte ich noch mal ein paar
Leute zitieren sehen sie sonst immer
gerne glauben erstens vom katholischen
Büro sagt die politischen Parteien
sollten den Weg für das Bürgergeld zügig
frei machen zweitens der Präsident der
Diakonie lässt sich zitieren dass ihre
Lösung nur die Regelsätze zu erhöhen ein
ganz schlechten Kompromiss sei und eine
überflüssige ideologische Debatte
geführt wird drittens die Caritas
twittert
schicken Stelle
was er jetzt ganz dringend kommen Liebe
Christdemokraten weniger Schattentheater
mehr Erleuchtung die Kirchen sind in
dieser Frage ein guter Kompass bitte
besinnen sie sich vielen Dank
mit einem Appell in die Unionsfraktion
und wenn wir hier mal in das Plenum des
Deutschen Bundestags schauen dann sehen
sie dass die reihen sich doch jetzt
deutlich füllen in gut nach 10 Minuten
werden wir es uns jetzt nicht völlig
verrechnet damals 10 12 Minuten wird dir
die erste namentliche Abstimmung
aufgerufen werden es werden weitere
folgen und wie das dann abläuft und
worum es da im Detail geht das erkläre
ich Ihnen gleich jetzt hören wir erstmal
Kai Whittaker aus der Unionsfraktion
wir streiten zu Recht darüber ob das
schon Vermögen zu hoch die Karenzzeiten
zu lang und die Leistungskürzungen
zulass sind sie als Ampel wollen das
fordern möglichst abschaffen wir wollen
es erhalten das ist weder Hetze noch
Populismus es ist schlicht und
ergreifend unsere politische Auffassung
und die einer überwiegenden Mehrheit der
Menschen in diesem Land
die Deutschen sind in überwältigender
Mehrheit bereit Menschen in Not zu
helfen aber sie erwarten auch dass jeder
alles dafür tut aus dieser Hilfe so
schnell wie möglich wieder
herauszukommen und damit bin ich beim
Herrn dieser Debatte was ist eigentlich
das Ziel dieses bürgergeldgesetzes wann
ist dieses Gesetz eigentlich ein Erfolg
und mir ist aufgefallen kein einziger
von ihnen hatte den Mut sich hier
hinzustellen und zu sagen wir wollen die
Zahl der Langzeitarbeitslosen halbieren
in den nächsten drei Jahren
die SPD ist froh dass der Name Hartz IV
ein bisschen weniger das der Name hat
hier weg ist und jetzt Bürgergeld heißt
die Grünen finden sich damit ab dass es
ein bisschen billiger Leistungskürzungen
gibt und die FDP ist glücklich darüber
dass man ein bisschen mehr
hinzuverdienen können das ist
ambitionslos beim fördern wäre deutlich
mehr drin gewesen für die Arbeit suchen
Chance vertan und das obwohl wir zwei
Millionen offene Stellen haben 500.000
neue Jobs jedes Jahr neuer
Beschäftigungsrekord mit über 45
Millionen Beschäftigten und gleichzeitig
fällt ihnen fast nichts ein wie man
langzeitarbeitslose Menschen wieder in
Arbeit bringt dabei müsste genau das das
Herzstück einer Reform sein meine Damen
und Herren
haben die Mitarbeiter einen Jobcenter
mehr Zeit um sich um Langzeitarbeitslose
zu kümmern nein weil sie jetzt ständig
gucken müssen ob Ihre Kunden noch
vertrauenszeit genießt oder schon raus
ist aus der kooperationszeit haben sie
Mitarbeiter mehr Geld um
Arbeitsmaßnahmen zu bezahlen nein sie
streichen die 600 Millionen Euro
verbessern sie die Beratungsqualität wie
ist die Bundesagentur für Arbeit anmahnt
nein gibt es vom Jobcenter durchgeführte
Sprachen und Integrationskurse mit
Kinderbetreuung damit gerade
ausländische Frauen eine Chance bekommen
nein machen sie es älteren Menschen ohne
Berufsabschluss attraktiver und leichter
eine Berufsausbildung zu machen nein all
diese Punkte wären notwendig denn wir
müssen beim fördern besser werden meine
Damen und Herren
und angesichts dessen ist es kein Wunder
dass kein einziger Arbeitsmarktexperte
bis heute gesagt hat dass dieses Gesetz
zu deutlich weniger Arbeitslosen führen
wird ein Satz zum Schluss wir haben die
Tag über heftig über dieses Gesetz
gestritten und man mag dieses Gesetz für
politisch falsch oder richtig halten
aber es hat mich schon entsetzt das SPD
grün und auch FDP nicht davor
zurückgeschreckt sind uns als Union Hass
und Hetze Populismus ja sogar ein
schlechtes Menschenbild zu unterstellen
bei aller Unterschiedlichkeit wenn wir
anfangen uns gegenseitig zu besichtigen
aus niederen Beweggründen oder in
schlechter Absicht Politik gegenüber den
Menschen zu betreiben dann legen Sie die
Axt an unsere demokratischen
Institutionen nicht die Lautstärke nicht
die Moral nicht dass sich ins rechts
setzen entscheidet hier sondern die
demokratische Debatte das Abwägen von
Argumenten und die Einsicht immer nur
die zweitbeste Lösung hier zu
beschließen vielen Dank
Fraktion appelliert an eine faire
Debatte rund ums Thema Bürgergeld und
wir hören dazu jetzt Beate Müller
Gemecker aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen sie ist Mitglied im Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales
sachlich begründet sein und darf ihnen
davon hat sich die Union bei Bürgergeld
gründlich verabschiedet sie haben eine
unsägliche Kampagne gestartet mit dem
sie Menschen mit kleinem Einkommen gegen
Erwerbslose ausspielen sie tun sie als
ob sich die Menschen bewusst und gezielt
in der Grundsicherung einrichten das ist
einfach nur billige Polemik das macht
was mit den Menschen die davon betroffen
sind hören Sie endlich damit auf
und die Union und Herr mietechniker
gerade wieder behauptet ja immer beim
fördern wäre mehr drin gewesen das ist
quatsch das Gegenteil ist der Fall der
neue kooperationsplan wird gleich nach
Antragsstellung intensiv und gemeinsam
erarbeitet wir schaffen den
vermittlungsvorgang ab und ermöglichen
damit Unterstützung die wirklich zu den
Menschen passt besonders wir machen ein
ganzheitliches Coaching und besonders
junge Menschen sollen stärker vor
während und nach der Ausbildung
begleitet werden das war uns Grün in den
Verhandlungen ein besonderes Anliegen
und außerdem und außerdem schaffen wir
die
außerdem entfristen wir den sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt und das alles zeigt
natürlich kümmern wir uns um die
Menschen das fördern wird besser
und zentrales
und zentrales Thema ist die
Qualifizierung die Zahl der
abschlussbezogenen
Weiterbildungsmaßnahmen sind gering
obwohl die Mehrheit der
Langzeitarbeitslosen Menschen kein
Berufsabschluss hat und das genau das
wollen wir ändern und deshalb stärken
wir die Qualifizierung mit einem
Weiterbildungsgeld mit einem
bürgergeldbonus damit eben Integration
in Arbeit besser gelingt die Union
interessiert das kein bisschen sie will
diese Verbesserungen blockieren und beim
Thema Qualifizierung ist das nicht
nachvollziehbar und auch nicht
akzeptabel
und um wen geht es hier eigentlich wenn
wir über das Bürgergeld reden und auch
das muss mal wohl für die Union geklärt
werden das sind rund zwei Millionen
Kinder und Jugendlichen fast zwei
Drittel der Erwerbsfähigen Menschen sind
gar nicht arbeitslos sie arbeiten und
stocken ihre niedrigen Lohn auf sie
pflegen Angehörige sie betreuen kleine
Kinder viele haben gesundheitliche
Einschränkungen und ich sage es ganz
deutlich niemand hat das Recht diese
Menschen zu stigmatisieren
die das machen sie Tag für Tag die einen
brauchen einfach bessere Löhne und die
anderen brauchen Unterstützung
Qualifizierung und des soziale Teilhabe
und alle brauchen neue Chancen und
Perspektiven und genau das gehen wir an
mit dem neuen Bürgergeld mit einem
Perspektivwechsel bei der
Arbeitsförderung und wenn sie die Union
endlich mal nicht ideologisch sondern
fachlich auf das Gesetz schauen würden
dann würden sie auch die Verbesserung
sehen da bin ich mir ganz sicher vielen
Dank
Beate Müller Gemecker aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen war die
drittletzte Rednerin in der Debatte zum
bürgergeldgesetz und zu den Anträgen die
zu diesem Thema hier im Plenum vorliegen
und dann gibt es hier eine Reihe von
Abstimmungen das werden wir uns gleich
mal von der Bundestagspräsidentin
erläutern lassen zunächst aber mag wir
das Haus der Unionsfraktion
gegen den und Kollegen dass der Kollege
Herr Klingbeil als Vorsitzender der SPD
unseren Fraktionsvorsitzenden mit Donald
Trump vergleicht und ihm Fake News und
Spaltung vorwirft das ist nicht nur
unverschämt sondern selbst spalterisch
und ein Tiefpunkt jeglicher
demokratischer und inhaltlicher Debatte
meine Damen und Herren
die ampelregierung ist mit großen
Ankündigungen und selfies gestartet
spätestens jetzt müssten die allerdings
feststellen dass Regieren in
Krisenzeiten bedeutet Kompromisse zu
machen pragmatisch statt ideologisch zu
handeln doch sie machen einfach weiter
als nichts gewesen wäre heute wollen wir
ein rein ideologisches Bürgergeld gegen
jede fachliche Kritik verabschieden es
ist nicht nur die Union die ihr
Bürgergeld kritisiert der
Bundesrechnungshof der Landkreistag die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit die Jobcenter
Personalräte das Handwerk die
arbeitergeberverbände und eine Vielzahl
von Arbeitsmarktexperten diese Kritik
können sie doch nicht einfach
ignorieren Liebe Ampel
statt immer nur statt immer nur über
Kritik zu schimpfen wäre es an der Zeit
eigene Vorhaben zu überprüfen und zu
hinterfragen was wir derzeit erleben ist
ein stures Festhalten an
Koalitionsvereinbarungen mit der
Einführung des Bürgergeld vollzieht die
Bundesregierung eine Rolle rückwärts für
unseren Arbeitsmarkt und verabschiedet
sich vom erfolgreichen Prinzip von
fördern und fordern
fest steht meine Damen und Herren statt
von Problemlösungen ist die
Arbeitsmarktpolitik der Bundesregierung
geprägt von sozialdemokratischer
Vergangenheitsbewältigung viel Liebe
Ampel schaffen Hartz IV ab und mit der
sechs monatigen vertrauenszeit starten
Sie in ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen und das wollen wir nicht
als Union wollen wir keinen Menschen
aufgeben wir wollen das Menschen schnell
in Arbeit wiederkommen und in das
gesellschaftliche Leben integriert
werden und mit dem bürgergeldgesetz
machen Sie genau den falschen Ansatz
meine Damen und Herren so geht es nicht
aus unserer Sicht beschränken sie mit
ihren Handlungsspielräumen die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in den
Jobcentern und das kritisieren wir meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Ampel genau das kritisieren wir und
nicht die Erhöhung von den
hartz-iv-sätzen wir fordern die heute
auf stimmen Sie mit uns mit der Erhöhung
der Sätze von 53 Euro zum ersten Januar
und kommen Sie zurück mit uns an den
Verhandlungstisch wir reichen die Hand
wir haben ein Konzept lassen Sie uns
darüber verhandeln aber das
bürgergeldgesetz lehnen wir heute ab
sagt mag biaraz aus der Unionsfraktion
der hier auch noch mal auf die
gegenseitigen teilweise auch
grenzwertigen Vorwürfe gegeneinander in
dieser Debatte verwiesen hat Jens Park
ist der letzte Redner SPD-Fraktion
Berichterstatter für diesen
Bereich insbesondere für das Bürgergeld
um wen
geht es eigentlich bei dieser Debatte
ich habe es hier schon der letzten
Debatte bei der ersten gesagt ich bin
Kind des Ruhrgebiets
und ich weiß was es heißt für Menschen
ihren Job verlieren Strukturwandel
Zechenschließung Werkschließung bei
Thyssen auf einmal waren tausende
Menschen arbeitslos die vorher nie daran
gedacht hätten dass sie arbeitslos
werden und damit das Ruhrgebiet ja nicht
allein
Ostdeutschland gibt es ganz ähnliche
Erfahrung nach der Wende irgendeine
Zugang in westock Kamen da Unternehmen
geschlossen und plötzlich waren Menschen
arbeitslos
deshalb ist in Artikel 20 unseres
Grundgesetzes das Sozialstaatsprinzip so
wichtig das Bekenntnis zum Sozialstaat
ist ein Versprechen an uns alle ein
Versprechen das heißt wenn du deine
Arbeit verlierst lassen wir dich nicht
fallen und dieses Versprechen auch an
die arbeitende Mitte dieser Gesellschaft
werden wir hier und heute mit der
einführungsbürgergeldes erneuern
wir haben hier viel gehört zum Thema
Arbeit wir haben gehört Arbeit würde
sich nicht mehr lohnen und ja als
Sozialdemokratin und Sozialdemokraten
wissen wir dass das Problem auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt gibt aber die Probleme sind
auch der niedrigste und Sektor schlechte
Bezahlung miese Arbeitsbedingungen und
deswegen ist umso unredlicher dass die
Union sich dem Mindestlohn verweigert
hat und wir laden Sie einen kämpfen Sie
mit uns wie das gesagt hat für bessere
Tarifbindung und wir tun was auch
deswegen schaffen wir den
vermittlungsvorhang ab die Abschaffung
des vermittlungsfonds ist eine
Kampfansage an den niedrigen Sektor in
diesem Land keine Vermittlung Mensch
schlechte Jobs wenn es eine langfristige
Perspektive durchaus im Weiterbildung
gibt Ausbildungs-
Perspektive statt Prekariat das ist die
neue Stoßrichtung des Bürgergeldes und
um wen geht es eigentlich ich sage Ihnen
ich bin mir ganz sicher heute hören auch
sehr aufmerksam zum Beispiel die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiterinnen
von Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof zu
die haben den letzten Jahren geschuftet
um den Konzern zu retten und über die
Runden zu kommen trotzdem droht jetzt
vielleicht unverschuldet wegen
Managementfehlern die Arbeitslosigkeit
und trotzdem obwohl sie sich Mühe
gegeben haben hart gearbeitet haben
brauchen Sie vielleicht Unterstützung
und deshalb schaffen wir mit dem
Bürgergeld ein Sozialstaat der die
arbeitende Mitte nicht vergisst ein
Sozialstaat der mit schon Vermögen und
Karenzzeit die Lebensleistung dieser
Menschen anerkennt und das ist der
notwendige Kulturwandel
und trotzdem
möchte die Union wie auch schon beim
Mindestlohn diesem Gesetz nicht
zustimmen trotzdem wollen sie es
blockieren und verzögern Herr Gröhe gibt
wo dann steht wer zugestimmt hat und wer
nicht ich sage Ihnen diese Liste fällt
auf sie zurück und deswegen appelliere
ich an sie appelliere an Sie übernehmen
sie Verantwortung für die Menschen im
Land für den Sozialstaat stimmen Sie zu
und sorgen Sie auch dazu dass ihre
Länder aus dem Bundesrat tun herzlichen
Dank
Jens peik aus der SPD-Fraktion ist schon
ein Schritt weiter denn der Bundesrat
wird am kommenden Montag wahrscheinlich
schon ein erstes Mal auf dieses Gesetz
gucken und dann möglicherweise ein
Vermittlungsausschuss tätig werden
lassen Bärbel Bass jetzt mit dem
weiteren Prozedere
zum abstimmungsverlauf geben wir werden
jetzt gleich über einen Teil des
Gesetzentwurfs in der zweiten Beratung
namentlich abstimmen hierfür haben sie
ca 10 Minuten Zeit nach Schließung
dieser namentlichen Abstimmung folgen
drei
einfache Abstimmungen danach werde ich
die Sitzung bis zur Bekanntgabe des
Ergebnisses unterbrechen im Anschluss
daran folgt die namentliche
Schlussabstimmung für die wiederum ca 10
Minuten vorgesehen sind danach wird die
Sitzung für die Auszählung erneut
unterbrochen wenn ich dieses Ergebnis
bekannt gegeben haben werde ich über die
Beschlussempfehlung zu einem Antrag der
Fraktion DIE LINKE ebenfalls namentlich
abstimmen diese namentliche Abstimmung
läuft dann parallel zur Aussprache zur
Zusatzpunkt 4 für diese dritte
namentliche Abstimmung haben sie dann 30
Minuten Zeit
das Zeitfenster für die beiden ersten
namentlichen Abstimmung beträgt jeweils
zehn Minuten um einen zusammenhängenden
Abschluss des laufenden
Tagesordnungspunktes einigermaßen zu
gewährleisten ab der dritten
namentlichen Abstimmung sind für heute
jeweils 30 Minuten vorgesehen nicht
zuletzt im Hinblick auf parallele
Beratung in einigen Gremien insbesondere
im Haushaltsausschuss
wir kommen jetzt zur Abstimmung über den
von der Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur Änderungen des zweiten
Buches des Sozialgesetzbuches und
anderer Gesetze Einführung eines
Bürgergeldes hierzu liegt mehr eine
Erklärung nach Paragraph 31 unserer
Geschäftsordnung vor
der Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales
empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
4.360 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksachen
3.873 und
4.226 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
die Fraktion der cdu/csu hat beantragt
über den Gesetzentwurf in der
ausschussfassung getrennt abzustimmen
und zwar zum einen über die Artikel 5
Nummer 1F Nummer 5 Nummer 15 Nummer 17
Nummer 18
das sind die Paragraphen 28a 143 des 12
Buches Sozialgesetzbuch Fortschreibung
des Regelbedarfs der regelbedarfsstufen
und zum anderen über den Gesetzentwurf
im übrigen
ich rufe zunächst auf
die Artikel den Artikel 5 Nummer 1 f
Nummer 5 Nummer 15 Nummer 17 Nummer 18
in der ausschussfassung die Fraktion der
cdu/csu hat namentliche Abstimmung
verlangt die Abstimmung erfolgt in der
westlobby sie haben zu Abgabe ihrer
Stimme nach Eröffnung der Abstimmung
circa 10 Minuten Zeit ich bitte jetzt
die Schriftführerin und Schriftführer
die vorgesehenen Plätze einzunehmen das
ist erfolgt wie ich sehe
dann eröffne ich hiermit für zehn
Minuten die namentliche Abstimmung
so jetzt haben wir
Übung werde ich ihnen dann rechtzeitig
noch bekannt geben
so jetzt geht es große Gewusel hier los
wie man sieht nicht nur hier im Saal
sondern auch in der westlobby also auf
den Gängen rund um den Plenarsaal wo die
abstimmungsurnen bereits bereitstehen
für die Abgeordneten können wir uns
sicherlich auch angucken da werden jetzt
also die Abgeordneten ihr Votum abgeben
für einen Teil des bürgergeldgesetzes
und sie haben sicherlich mitbekommen was
Bärbel Bars die Bundestagspräsidentin
hier eben aufgerufen hat jetzt geht es
ausschließlich um den Bereich in diesem
bürgergeldgesetz der sich mit den
sogenannten Regelsätzen beschäftigt also
mit der Erhöhung
dessen der einzelnen der einzelnen Sätze
der Erhöhung dessen was jetzt unter ALG2
Hartz IV in der Regel läuft die Anhebung
um rund 50 Euro für einzelne Personen
das ist ja dann in anderen Bereichen
dann noch mal weiter ausdifferenziert
und das ist jetzt Parteipolitik was hier
passiert denn die Ampelkoalition wird
einer separaten und ausschließlich auf
diesen Regeln setzen
basierenden Abstimmungen natürlich nicht
zustimmen sie möchte das ganze Gesetz
durchbringen deswegen wird es hier
mutmaßlich einen Teil Erfolg geben für
die Unionsfraktion und da wird man der
Koalition vorhalten sie wollen noch
nicht einmal jedes die Regelsätze erhöht
werden das ist Politik ob das schlau ist
ist eine andere Frage aber ist dient
hier sicherlich auch noch mal zur
Polarisierung innerhalb dieser Debatte
die ohnehin ein klein wenig polarisiert
geführt worden ist in der vergangenen
etwas mehr als einen Stunde diese
Abstimmung läuft jetzt sie sehen
Hochbetrieb in der Lobby habe ich eben
in auch schon gesagt der Saal ist gerade
vergleichsweise leer das ganze wird gut
zehn Minuten dauern wir nutzen die
Gelegenheit um uns einzelne Teile der
heutigen Debatte noch einmal anzusehen
und den argumentationsaustausch den es
da gegeben hat und wir beginnen gleich
ganz vorne um ungefähr 9:15 Uhr trat sie
zunächst der Bundesarbeitsminister
Robert zum Teil ans Rednerpult und ihm
folgte dann Hermann Gröhe
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion mit seinen Argumenten in
dieser Watte aber wir beginnen während
wir noch die Bilder sehen aus der Lobby
wo auch schon ein Teil der Abstimmung
stattgefunden hat das geht ja schnell
zum Kärtchen einzuwerfen für ja oder
nein oder auch Enthaltung also während
wir das noch sehen jetzt erstmal der
Blick auf den Morgen und es beginnt
Hubertus Heil
das Bürger
Geld man ist die größte
sozialstaatsreform seit 20 Jahren wir
verfolgen als Bundesregierung als
Koalition damit vor allen Dingen zwei
Ziele ja es geht darum dass Menschen die
in existenzielle Not geraten sind
verlässlich und so unbürokratisch wie
möglich abgesichert werden aber das
reicht uns nicht wir wollen nicht nur
Schutz geben in Zeiten der Not wir
wollen Chancen auf den selbstbestimmtes
Leben schaffen ich habe es eben am
Beispiel dieses Mannes am sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt beschrieben aber wir sagen
das auch mit Blick auf die Realität der
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit in Deutschland
wenn es so ist dass zwei Drittel der
Langzeitarbeitslosen Menschen heute kein
abgeschlossenen Berufsabschluss haben
und sie im alten Hartz-IV-System dann
hin und wieder vielleicht mal in
Hilfstätigkeiten vermittelt werden aber
das Jobcenter sie nach ein paar Monaten
wieder sieht und sie nicht dauerhaft
nachhaltig in Arbeit vermittelt werden
dann ist im System was falsch mit dem
Bürgergeld ändern wir das wir schaffen
die Chance dass Menschen nicht in
Hilfstätigkeiten vermittelt werden
müssen sondern ein Berufsabschluss
nachholen können um dauerhaft und Arbeit
zu sein dass es auch ein Beitrag
Arbeitskräfte
für den Bürgergeld reagieren wir auf
zwei fundamentale Veränderungen erstens
ist der Arbeitsmarkt heute ein völlig
anderer als vor 20 Jahren damals hatten
wir Massenarbeitslosigkeit heute in
vielen Bereichen Arbeits- und
Fachkräftemangel und zweitens ist es
wichtig aus den Erfahrungen der Krisen
der letzten Jahre auch der aktuellen
Krise zu lernen wenn es darum geht für
weniger Bürokratie im System und für
mehr Respekt für die Menschen zu sorgen
für Notlagen meine Damen und Herren
brauchen wir Lösungen die funktionieren
so unbürokratisch und so
bürgerfreundlich wie möglich wir sorgen
mit den Bürgergeld dafür dass wir
überflüssige Bürokratien den Jobcentern
abbauen damit die Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeiter in der Jobcenter die
übrigens eine hervorragende Arbeit
leisten tatsächlich sich auf das
Wesentliche konzentrieren können ein
Beispiel ist das was die Jobcenter immer
gefordert haben zum Beispiel eine
Bagatellgrenze für Kleinstbeträge wo
Menschen mit Bescheiden belästigten
überzogen werden dann lohnt weder
Aufwand noch nutzen das schaffen wir ab
vor allen Dingen meine Damen und Herren
aber sorgen wir für angemessenen Schutz
ein wichtiger Teil der Reform ist die
Erhöhung des Regelsatzes es geht darum
dass das Bürgergeld was die Erhöhung und
Anpassung der Regelsätze betrifft der
Inflationsentwicklung zukünftig nicht
mehr hinterherlaufen das ist gerade
jetzt besonders wichtig aber ich sage
auch klar und deutlich damit kann es
nicht getan sein die Qualität eines
Sozialstaats bemisst sich nicht allein
an der Höhe des sozialen Transfers
sondern die Qualität des Sozialstaats
bemisst sich vor allen Dingen daran wie
sehr er in der Lage ist Menschen zu
einem selbstbestimmten Leben am Arbeit
zu bringen und ich sage es noch mal ein
Beispiel des Mannes den ich eingangs
genannt habe der hat mir erzählt was er
in den 15 Jahren erlebt hat wie er sich
die fingerbund geschrieben hat wie ihm
die Decke auf den Kopf gefallen ist und
dem Mann geht es heute besser in Arbeit
er sagt ich fühle mich wertgeschätzt ich
leiste was ich habe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren für die
Mehrheit der Menschen in Deutschland ist
Arbeit mehr als Brot Erwerb es ist Geld
verdienen aber es ist Teilhabe am
gesellschaftlichen Leben und damit
sorgen auch mit Bürgergeld dafür dass
Leistungssystem
und wir setzen Anreize ein
Berufsabschluss nachzu und ermöglichen
das nicht nur denn wir das einmal bei
Menschen erlebt hat die ein
Berufsabschluss verpasst haben die sich
dann wieder aufrappeln das ist sehr
anstrengend und wir wollen das
leistungszielt und das auch mit
finanziellen Anreizen belohnt wird mit
dem Weiterbildungsgeld wir werden dafür
sorgen und da bin ich den
koalitionsfraktion sehr dankbar dass wir
uns darauf verständigt haben dass wir
Zuverdienstgrenzen im Bürgergeld erhöhen
damit Leistung sich lohnt das war nicht
nur ein Anliegen der FDP aber die FDP
hat sich besonders dafür eingesetzt ganz
herzlichen Dank dafür
und jetzt meine Damen und Herren muss
ich an die Adresse der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion mal meiner
Verwunderung Ausdruck bringen dass sie
heute den Antrag stellen dass nur der
Regelsatz erhöht wird wenn sie
wochenlang rumlaufen und sagen mit den
Bürgergeld lohnt sich Arbeit nicht mehr
und gleichzeitig nur den Regelsatz
erhöhen dann ist ein gewisser logischer
Bruch um das ganz deutlich zu sagen
denn Arbeit muss ein Unterschied machen
arbeit muss sich lohnen in Deutschland
und dafür sorgt die Koalition deshalb
haben wir den Mindestlohn erhöht meine
Damen und Herren auf 12 Euro und die
cdu/cs gehört nicht mitgestimmt
deshalb kämpfen wir für mehr
Tarifbindung und brauchen auch da noch
ein bisschen Unterstützung kann die
Union sich auch verdient machen deshalb
haben wir das Wohngeld heute auf der
Tagesordnung gerade in diesen Zeiten
deshalb haben wir Beiträge und Steuern
für Geringverdiener gesorgt den Arbeit
müssen Unterschied machen aber in diesen
Zeiten in denen die gesellschaftliche
Stimmung angespannt ist aufgrund der
Krise werden und dürfen keine
demokratischen Demokraten zulassen das
geringverdienende Menschen gegen
bedürftige Menschen ausgespielt werden
wir müssen die gesamte Gesellschaft im
Blick haben und dieses Land
zusammenrechnen es ist völlig verfehlt
dass sie in der Bereich der Integration
in Arbeit 600 Millionen Euro kürzen
wollen tun sie doch nicht so als hilft
ein neuer Name wenn sie beim Geld für
die Jobcenter kürzen für uns als Union
war stets klar Vorfahrt für Vermittlung
wir halten am fordern fest aber wir
müssen beim fördern besser werden wir
wollen nicht das alles so bleibt wie sie
es permanent unterstellen
heute verweigern sie jede sachliche
Debatte über die grundsätzlichen
wetfehler ihres Gesetzes ich dachte
zunächst da sei die ampelangst vor
Argumenten inzwischen weiß ich sie haben
sogar vor unseren Fragen Angst es ist
doch ungeheuerlich dass sie es der
Opposition verweigern dem
Bundesrechnungshof in einer Anhörung
dieses Parlaments zu befragen eine
Institution der das Grundgesetz
richterliche Unabhängigkeit zuschreibt
und sie wollen diese Antworten nicht im
Parlament hören unglaublich
glauben Sie eigentlich im Ernst glauben
Sie im Ernst die Arroganz der Mehrheit
im Bundestag erhöht die Chancen auf eine
Mehrheit im Bundesrat wer empfiehlt ihn
eigentlich so absurde Strategien bis
doch unglaublich ja die Zeit wird knapp
wir wollen am 1 Januar bessere
Bedingungen für die Menschen die
langzeitarbeitslos sind aber der
kabinettszeitplan ist der
kabinettszeitplan der Ampel der
parlamentszeitplan ist der
parlamentszeitplan der Ampel wir haben
zu keiner Zeit irgendetwas verzögert im
Gegenteil es waren die
arbeitsministerinnen und Minister der
Union die vor einer Woche an Sie als
Fraktionen der Ampel geschrieben haben
um welche grundsätzlichen Bedenken es
ging wir wollten uns ein
Vermittlungsverfahren ersparen wir
wollten Ihnen die Gelegenheit geben sich
zu korrigieren Sie haben die ungenutzt
verstreichen lassen
und trotz aller persönlichen
Herabsetzungen sei mal darauf
hingewiesen die Personalräte der
Jobcenter drängen auf eine Verschiebung
sie schreiben lesen Sie den Brandbrief
sie drängen darauf
sie nein ich weiß dass sie das Herr dürr
also im Schulhof gilt wer brüllt hat
Unrecht für Herrn Bürgel das sogar im
Parlament meine Damen meine Herren also
das originell die Zeit der Abstimmung so
meine Damen und Herren da sind wir
wieder live nachdem wir Hermann Gröhe
noch mal gehört haben und davor den
Bundesarbeitsminister zwischenzeitlich
haben wir auch schon den Bundeskanzler
gesehen der hier natürlich mit abstimmt
in dieser Debatte und die erste
Abstimmung ist hier gleich beendet wir
sehen und hören was Bundestags
Präsidentin Bars sagt
Abstimmung zur Beschlussempfehlung des
Ausschusses für Arbeit und Soziales auf
Drucksache
4.360 fort unter Buchstabe b
empfiehlt der Ausschuss die Ablehnung
des Antrages der Fraktion der AFD auf
Drucksache
3.943 mit dem Titel
aktivierende Grundsicherung statt
bedingungslosem Grundeinkommen
Einführung von Bürgerarbeit wer stimmt
für die Beschlussempfehlung
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP cdu/csu wer
stimmt dagegen das ist die afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen kann ich nicht erkennen
dann ist die Beschlussempfehlung so
angenommen und das bedeutet der Antrag
der AFD ist abgelehnt jetzt geht es
weiter mit drei Anträgen der
Linksfraktion die Linke auf Drucksache
3901 mit dem Titel sozialen Arbeitsmarkt
ausbauen
1.150.000
Langzeitarbeitslose in Erwerbsarbeit
bringen so ist es richtig wer stimmt für
die Beschlussempfehlung das sind die
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
FDP cdu/csu-fraktion und die
afd-fraktion Gegenstimmen sie Fraktion
DIE LINKE Enthaltungen
sehe ich nicht dann ist die
Beschlussempfehlung so angenommen und
auch hier gilt damit ist der Antrag
abgelehnt das wird jetzt auch für die
beiden folgenden so sein deswegen spare
ich mir da ein zwischen Kommentar
Sanktionen abschaffen keine Kürzungen am
Existenzminimum vornehmen wer stimmt für
die Beschlussempfehlung das sind die
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
FDP cdu/csu und die afd-fraktion
Gegenprobe das Ablehnung bei der
Fraktion DIE LINKE Enthaltungen kann ich
nicht erkennen damit ist die
Beschlussempfehlung so angenommen
bis zum Vorliegen des Ergebnisses der
ersten namentlichen Abstimmung
unterbreche ich jetzt kurz die Sitzung
so und da müssen wir jetzt mal ein
bisschen spekulieren wie lange das wohl
dauern wird die Abstimmung ist beendet
worden vor knapp nach ich sag mal drei
Minuten glaube ich dann hat der die
Bundestagspräsidentin ja hier bereits
zwei Anträge aufgerufen und abstimmen
lassen ein drei sogar ein dritter Antrag
aus den Rhein der Linksfraktion wird
nachher noch namentlich abgestimmt
werden ist ist ein bisschen anders als
sonst hier heute aber wir versuchen mit
ihnen und mit der Bundestagspräsidentin
den Überblick zu behalten wie gesagt die
Sitzung ist jetzt unterbrochen weil die
Abstimmung von eben ausgezählt wird in
der es ja darum ging dass die
Unionsfraktion gefordert hatte dass nur
über einen Teil des bürgergeldgesetzes
abgestimmt wird nämlich über die
Regelsätze da ist die Union ja durchaus
dafür dass die Regelsätze dann aber für
ALG2 bzw Hartz IV im Anfang nächsten
Jahres steigen sollen aber die Koalition
macht wenn das nicht mit weil sie sagt
wir wollen über das ganze
bürgergeldgesetz abstimmen und nicht nur
über einzelne Punkte aus Sicht der
Koalition ist das ganze Jahr auch als
ein Gesamtwerk zu betrachten so
Sitzungsunterbrechung wir rechnen mit
gut zehn Minuten die es braucht um die
Stimmkarten auszuzählen wir bereiten uns
auch schon mal hier so ein bisschen auf
die mehrheitszahlen vor und wir nutzen
die Gelegenheit noch einmal auf weitere
debattenteile und Rednerinnen Redner
zurückzuschauen und sie zusammenzufassen
und das bedeutet dass wir Ihnen jetzt
noch mal zeigen Norbert Kleinwächter aus
der afd-fraktion unter vorbräter
Hasselmann die Vorsitzende der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und dann sind wir
in knapp zehn Minuten wieder live dabei
die Diskussion über eine dieser größten
Sozialreformen der letzten Jahrzehnte
nämlich das Bürgergeld ist eine sehr
wichtige und sie wird sehr kontrovers
geführt
lieber Hermann Gröhe ich habe sie hier
schon sehr oft reden gehört und ich
schätze sie sehr aber ihre Rede hat
gezeigt wie schwer es ihnen fällt die
Position von Friedrich Merz und Söder zu
vertreten
meine Damen und Herren wer keine
Argumente in der Sache hat verliert sich
im Verfahren und das wird dem Anliegen
das mit dem Bürgergeld verbunden wird
mit den vielen Menschen die davon
profitieren werden und die betroffen
sind in keiner Weise gerecht meine Damen
und Herren und
ein Stress
Friedrich Merz spitzt zwar die Lippen
öffentlich ja und er geht sich in
Vorurteilen gegenüber Menschen die
betroffen sind die von Arbeitslosigkeit
betroffen sind die arm sind die in
prekären Beschäftigungsverhältnissen
Leben schürt sozial Neid ohne Ende eine
solche soziale Kälte in Krisenzeiten
kaum zu ertragen und verantwortungslos
aber hier im Parlament
hier in Parlament kneift er heute es ist
auch einfacher Interviews zu geben bei
denen keiner widersprechen kann meine
Damen und Herren weil heute wären wir
mit ihren Argumenten die sie öffentlich
führen mit Ihnen hier scharf ins Gericht
gegangen meine Damen und Herren
aber meine Damen und Herren
es geht halt um die
Lebenswirklichkeiten die sind in diesem
Land verschieden
und wie soll jemand der in einer ganz
anderen Lebenswirklichkeit lebt und sich
vielleicht überlegen muss ob er zur
Party mit dem Privatjet oder mit dem
Auto oder den Zug fliegt
wie soll sie Erziehenden Frau versetzen
die überlegen muss ob sie ein paar neue
Turnschuhe für das Kind kaufen kann oder
ob sie vielleicht heute einen Ausflug
machen kann in einer Eisdiele und mehr
als drei Kugeln Eis für ihre drei Kinder
drin sind da kann man auch nicht
erwarten dass man sich da reinversetzen
kann aber was ich von ihnen erwarte ist
Respekt Respekt vor der Lebenslage eines
jeden Menschen und den haben sie nicht
meine Damen und Herren
das Bürgergeld ist viel mehr als
einen satzerhöhung und deshalb
beschließen wir es heute auch insgesamt
es ist eine Reform des Arbeitsmarktes es
wird Veränderungen bringen denn meine
Damen und Herren das Bürgergeld schafft
Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung es
schafft Perspektiven für Menschen und
selbstverständlich geht es um
Vermittlung aber es geht nicht mehr
einfach nur um bloß zu Vermittlung
sondern um Qualifizierung und
Beschäftigung
meine Damen und Herren es geht darum des
zweiten Buches Sozialgesetzbuch und
anderer Gesetze zur Einführung eines
Bürgergeldes Tierartikel 5 Nummer 1F
Nummer 5 Nummer 15 Nummer 17 Nummer 18
die § 28a 134 SGB 7
Fortschreibung der regelbedarfsstufen
abgegebene Stimmkarten
683 mit Jahr haben gestimmt 681 mit Nein
hat niemand gestimmt es gab zwei
Enthaltungen
damit ist
sind die übrigen Teile des
Gesetzentwurfs angenommen und alle zu
wir kommen jetzt zur Schlussabstimmung
und damit zur nein
ach so Entschuldigung ja ich habe in
genau wir haben hier in der Übergabe ein
kleines Problem also wir setzen die
Abstimmung zu dem Entwurf eines
Bürgergeldes Gesetzes der
Bundesregierung fort und jetzt rufe ich
auf die übrigen Teile des
Gesetzentwurfes in der ausschussfassung
diejenigen die den übrigen Teilen des
Gesetzentwurfs in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen bitte ich um das
Handzeichen
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
vielen Dank damit sind die übrigen Teile
des Gesetzentwurfes angenommen bei
Zustimmung durch die koalitionsfraktion
cdu/csu und AFD haben dagegen gestimmt
die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat sich
enthalten damit sind jetzt alle Teile
des Gesetzentwurfes in zweiter Beratung
angenommen und wir kommen zur dritten
Beratung und Schlussabstimmung und damit
zur zweiten namentlichen Abstimmung sie
haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme
sie haben zur abgebung zur Abgabe ihrer
Stimme wiederum zehn Minuten Zeit ich
weiß jetzt schon darauf hin dass nach
der namentlichen Abstimmung während der
Auszählung des Ergebnisses die Sitzung
unterbrochen wird ich bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer die
vorgesehenen Plätze einzunehmen das ist
bereits der Fall
dann eröffne ich die namentliche
Abstimmung für nunmehr zehn Minuten
so das muss jetzt noch mal ein bisschen
nachsortieren für höhere Regelsätze also
alle da hat es im Vorfeld
unterschiedliche Aussagen gegeben und
diesen Punkt haben wir jetzt
abgeschlossen jetzt ist auch die zweite
Beratung abgeschlossen worden und jetzt
sind wir bei der
Schlussabstimmung das ist jetzt die denn
[Musik]
innerhalb der dritten Beratung und dann
wird das bürgergeldgesetz mit den
Stimmen der Koalition da wird es ja
nicht mehr eine so deutliche Mehrheit
oder eine so deutliche Jahr anstimmen
geben für das bürgergeldgesetz sondern
da wird die eine Koalition ihre
Stimmen von 416 auf die Waagschale
bringen und dann muss man beobachten wie
sich die Linke beispielsweise dazu
verhält die ja durchaus einiges an
Kritik geäußert hat an diesem
bürgergeldgesetz und auch die Regelsätze
beispielsweise die Regelsatzerhöhung für
zu niedrig hält das bedeutet dass wir
jetzt hier wieder eine Unterbrechung
haben im Plenum für diese Abstimmung
dafür immer wieder knapp zehn Minuten
angesetzt und das gibt uns die
Gelegenheit noch mal zu schauen auf die
Debatte die wir gesehen haben und wir
machen es jetzt mit einem Ausschnitt aus
dem Reden von Johannes Vogel und Dietmar
Bartsch
demokratie lebt von Wettstreit der
Argumente und die Opposition soll
deswegen natürlich die Koalition
kritisieren auch beim Bürgergeld nehmen
wir das Beispiel schon vermögen wir sind
der Meinung dass wenn zum Beispiel ein
selbstständiger durch einen
Schicksalsschlag auf die Grundsicherung
angewiesen ist dass er nicht als erstes
seine Altersvorsorge aufbrauchen soll
sie sehen das anders das ist ihr gutes
Recht darüber können wir hier streiten
es macht aber einen zentralen
Unterschied und das hat ist bei mir bei
dieser Debatte wirklich wichtig es macht
einen zentralen Unterschied ob man ein
alternatives politisches Urteil fällt
oder ob man alternative Fakten erfindet
und das haben wir hier in der
bürgerkette erlebt wir brauchen in der
Demokratie und das ist mir wirklich
ernst eine gemeinsame debattengrundlage
auf Basis von Fakten und
mir liegt hier der sitzungswöchentliche
Brief von Friedrich Merz aus der letzten
Sitzungswoche erste Lesung Bürgergeld
vor wo sich schwarz auf weiß Aussagen
finden die wir auch die letzten Tage
immer wieder in der Debatte gehört haben
mit dem Bürgergeld soll eine
sechs-monatige sanktionsfreie Karenzzeit
eingeführt werden sagen Sie Herr Merz
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
schlicht nicht wahr es stimmt nicht es
gibt keine sanktionsfreien Zeiten im
Bürgergeld sondern 80 Prozent der
Sanktionen werden auch den ersten sechs
Monaten weiter verhängt und danach sogar
das volle verfassungsrechtlich mögliche
Maße es ist kein Geheimnis Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Grünen netten sich das
anders gewünscht das ist auch okay in
einer Demokratie aber wer etwas anderes
verbreitet der verbreitet Fake News und
das geht nicht in der demokratischen
Debatte
ein weiteres Zitat aus ihrem Brief die
Regelsätze sollen über die
Inflationsanpassung hinaus angehoben
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das ist schlicht nicht wahr es stimmt
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Union an der rechnungsmethode der
Regelsätze ändert sich nichts zu Recht
gleichen wir die Inflation nicht mehr
anderthalb Jahre später aus das auch
eine Frage der Fairness und ja es ist
bekannt manche Kollegen und Kollegen aus
Koalitionsfraktionen von SPD und Grünen
hätten sich eine andere
Berechnungsmethode gewünscht aber das
steht nicht im Gesetzentwurf den wir
hier beraten und vollends schizophren
wird es wenn sie behaupten durch das
Bürgergeld lohne sich Arbeit in
Deutschland nicht mehr das ist erstens
in jedem einzelnen Fall falsch und
zweitens polemisieren sie damit gegen
eine Berechnungsmethode der Regelsätze
die eine CDU-Ministerin selber
eingeführt hat liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist doch schizophren und
unredlich richtig ist dass in unserem
Sozialstaat übrigens vorgegeben durch
Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts die Ansprüche
auf das Existenzminimum zum Beispiel bei
großen Familien so hoch sind dass ein
allein verlieren mit Mindestlohn das
nicht alleine durch sein Arbeitslohn
erwirtschaftet das ist richtig das ist
Ausdruck auch des sozialstaatsprinzips
das gibt unsere Verfassung vor das hat
aber genau nichts mit dem Bürgergeld zu
tun weil das heute schon so der Fall ist
und auch richtigerweise der Fall ist die
Frage ist also wie können wir dafür
sorgen dass sich Anstrengung zum
Beispiel auch bei diesen großen Familien
wenn Menschen arbeiten stärker lohnt
heute schon gibt es keinen Fall wo der
der arbeitet weniger hat als der der
nicht arbeitet und das auch richtig
durch Kindergeld Kinderzuschlag Wohngeld
all das was wir auch jetzt Anpassen an
die Inflation aber richtig ist es muss
sich stärker lohnen und dann muss man an
ein Thema ran was mir in der Tat sehr am
Herzen liegt nämlich das Thema
zuverdienstregeln und deshalb ist es
auch so absurd was die Union diese Woche
vorschlägt nämlich einfach nur die
Regelsätze zu erhöhen ohne durch die
Reform des Bürgergeldes auch für mehr
Leistungsgerechtigkeit und
Aufstiegschancen zu sorgen das müssen
wir doch tun es muss sich mehr lohnen
Schritt für Schritt rauszuwachsen aus
der Grundsicherung und das schaffen wir
jetzt endlich das ist Kern der Bürger
der Reform liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und damit machen wir übrigens auch klar
dass junge Menschen diesem Land endlich
stärker Piloten des eigenen Lebens
werden heute lohnt sich nämlich auch
eine Ausbildung nicht das machen wir
anders das machen wir besser durchs
Bürgergeld heute werden zum Beispiel
wenn Annika die in einer
hartz-iv-familie groß wird im Minijob
arbeitet kann sie von 520 Euro 184
behalten wenn eische deren Eltern
finanziell auf eigenen Beinen stehen
denselben Minijob macht dann kann sie
520 Euro behalten junge Menschen
Verfahren schon in diesem Land heute vor
dem Bürgergeld am Anfang ihres Lebens
dass ich ihre Anstrengung nicht lohnt
das ist kein Unterschied macht wenn sie
arbeiten dass sie schlechtere Chancen
haben wegen weil ihre Eltern in
schwieriger Lagen sind das ist das
Gegenteil von Chancen Unabhängigkeit
unabhängig von der Herkunft und das
verbessern wir endlich
durch mehr Leistungsgerechtigkeit und
Aufstiegschancen
das macht nämlich vor allem was in den
Köpfen meine Fraktion hat diese Woche
drei junge Menschen nach Berlin
eingeladen Ferrat Sarah und Alex jeder
kann sich ihre Geschichten gerade seit
heute morgen auf Youtube anschauen sie
beschreiben sehr eindrücklich was das
was das in den Köpfen und den Herzen
macht wenn man schlechtere Chancen hat
wegen der Familie in die man geboren
wurde wir müssen uns doch nicht wundern
dass in unserem Land Chancen stärker von
der Herkunft abhängen wenn wir bereits
am Anfang des Lebens junge Menschen
Steine in den Weg legen das schaffen wir
endlich ab und darauf bin ich stolz denn
für diese Menschen kämpfen wir und
machen unser Sozialstaat fairer deshalb
stimmen wir heute für das Bürgergeld
vielen Dank das was die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger aktuell erleben das ist nicht
anders zu bezeichnen als ein
Schmierentheater die Wirtschaftsweisen
haben angesichts der Krise höhere
Steuern für die Topverdiener verlangt
völlig zurecht und Union lehnen das ab
sie spielen stattdessen Geringverdiener
gegen Arbeitslose aus das
Milliardenvermögen der Superreichen
schützen und das sogenannte
Schonvermögen von Menschen die
jahrzehntelang gearbeitet haben in Frage
stellen das ist unwürdig insbesondere
mit dem Blick auf das C in ihrem Namen
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen liebe Britta Hasselmann die
Lebenswirklichkeit die
Lebenswirklichkeit ist dass die
Regelsätze jetzt 449 49 Euro betragen
ich erinnere daran dass im Januar die
Regelsätze um drei Euro erhöht worden
sind das war erbärmlich das war der
Staat der Koalition drei Euro so viel
kostet heute ein Stück Butter die
Inflation liegt bei zehn Prozent sie
hätten die Regelsätze schon im Sommer
mindestens um diese 53 Euro anheben
müssen jetzt laufen die Tafel übrig
Fortschritt Koalition in der Realität
ist das eine Schnarch Informationen
immer zu spät und immer zu wenig das ist
die Realität meine Damen und Herren bei
den Energiepreisen der gelungen viel zu
spät Erhöhung der Regelsätze Inflation
verpennt jetzt ist November sie mit
ihrer briesigkeit haben Friedrich Merz
erst ermöglicht dass es die Wahrheit
meine Damen und Herren wir wir erkennen
ganz klar an wir erkennen ganz klar an
es gibt Fortschritte Hubertus Heil hat
das an einem Beispiel eindringlich
geschildert Schüler Azubis studierende
können deutlich mehr behalten von ihren
Verdiensten das ist gut die zweijährige
Karenzzeit beim Wohnen sicherlich
positiv überhaupt keine Frage aber bei
allen Fortschritten bei allen
Fortschritten das Bürgergeld ist nicht
im
ansatzarmutsfest 53 Euro bleiben Armut
per Gesetz meine Damen und Herren
bedrückt sich man die Inflation sind das
0,0 meine Damen und Herren liebe
Sozialdemokraten und Sozialdemokraten
was steht in eurem Wahlprogramm die
Regel im neuen Bürgergeld müssen zu
einem Leben in Würde ausreichen und zur
gesellschaftlichen Teilhabe befähigen
mit 53
Euro für ein Käse und was steht noch in
EUR
em Bürgergeld muss absichern dass eine
kaputte Waschmaschine und eine neue
Winterjacke nicht zu untragbaren Last
werden das leistet das Bürgergeld
ausdrücklich nicht das Bürgergeld ist zu
wenig für würde und auch zu wenig für
eine neue Waschmaschine meine Damen und
Herren Bürgergeld sind gut aber real ist
das eben keine Abkehr von Hartz IV das
System bleibt erhalten in Substanz ist
es Hartz 5 meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von denen die
meinen die Regelsätze dürfen nicht
armutsfest sein und das Schonvermögen
müsste möglichst gering sein da wird
immer dann das Lohnabstandsgebot
angeführt wie absurd ist das denn wir
haben kein Problem mit zu hohen
Regelsätzen wir haben aber einen
Million und das wird dann zu einem
Rentenproblem im Verkauf in der Pflege
bei den Dienstleistungen sind die Löhne
schlicht zu niedrig die Löhne müssen
rauf und nicht die Leistung politisch
klein gerechnet werden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie immer auch
das Kind heißen mag am 1 Januar müssen
die Sätze steigen und wir brauchen
schleunigst dann eine realistische
Neuberechnung die den Mensch die die
Menschen wirklich tatsächlich vor Armut
schützt und ein Leben in Würde
garantiert und in der Zwischenzeit da
brauchen wir monatliche Zuschläge wie
das in unserem Antrag steht das wäre
eine Brücke meine Damen und Herren und
der Union kann ich nur zurufen hören sie
mit ihrer Blockade auf kein
Verschiebebahnhof zum ersten siebten die
Lage ist für die Betroffenen vielfach
dramatisch nehmen Sie bitte diese
Menschen in den Blick herzlichen Dank
Dietmar Bartsch und davor Johannes Vogel
außer Debatte zum Bürgergeld Gesetz und
wenn wir jetzt hier in den Plenarsaal
des Deutschen Bundestages gucken dann
sehen wir das ja relativ gut besetzt ist
das liegt an folgendem die Abstimmung
die Schlussabstimmung die namentliche
Schlussabstimmung zum bürgergeldgesetz
ist beendet und im Moment wird
ausgezählt so lange ist die Sitzung hier
unterbrochenen unterbrochen wir rechnen
mit einem Ergebnis in ca 5-6 Minuten und
wir nutzen die Gelegenheit noch mal zwei
weitere Redner zu hören aus dieser
Debatte nämlich jetzt heute Trainer aus
der FDP-Fraktion und Kai Whittaker aus
der Unionsfraktion und wie gesagt den
5-6 Minuten werden wir dann hier das
Ergebnis der Schlussabstimmung haben
im Zentrum des Bürgergeld steht es nicht
wie immer wieder behauptet wird mehr
Lässigkeit im Zentrum des Bürgergeld
steht das Leistungsprinzip und
Berufseinstiegschancen durch
Qualifizierung also die nachhaltige
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt das ist
das Zentrum des Bürgergeldes und wenn
man ein Beispiel nennen müsste ein
einziges Beispiel an dem man das
festmacht dann sind es Auszubildende die
in einer Hartz iv-bedarfsgemeinschaft
aufwachsen wenn die aktuell dort 800
Euro Ausbildungsvergütung haben dann
bleiben ihm faktisch nur 240 Euro der
Rest wird angerechnet das
Hartz-IV-System was sie verteidigen was
sie nicht verändert haben sagt diesen
jungen Menschen eine Ausbildung und
Arbeit lohnt sich nicht jetzt ist es so
beim Bürgergeld von 800 Euro dürfen die
6004 Euro behalten das ist mehr als das
2,5 Wasser die Botschaft des
Sozialstaates ist klar es lohnt sich zu
arbeiten es lohnt sich eine Ausbildung
und wenn sie jetzt
wie kann das denn sein dass er überhaupt
noch was angerechnet wird das ist alles
nur Aufstiegs Lyrik nein das verändert
bei jungen Menschen etwas im Kopf es
verändert die Botschaft und wenn sie
sagen wieso ist das zu wenig wieso haben
sie es in den letzten Jahren nie
angepasst wenn das doch eigentlich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit war weil es ihn
nicht um diese jungen Menschen geht
sondern es geht um eine Scheindebatte
und die Scheindebatte Herr Gröhe haben
wir erlebt sie haben gerade eben wieder
vorgeworfen den brandbeef der
Personalräte der Brand lief der
Personalräte kam zum ersten
Gesetzesentwurf wir haben den
Gesetzesentwurf angepasst das so dass
beim zum ersten ersten nur die
Regelsätze in Kraft treten die
Karenzzeit und die Bagatellgrenze auf
Wunsch der BA die BA wünscht sich dass
dieser Punkte zum ersten Kraft tritt
alles andere wird nach hinten verschoben
die BA hat in der Anhörung gesagt sie
findet das total gut dass das
stattfindet sie hat gesagt sie braucht
diese Vorbereitungszeit und wünsche euch
dass der Bundesrat schnell zu einer
Entscheidung kommt weil eine Bacardi in
schaden würde ihr Kollege Stracke ist
dann zur Presse gegangen hat gesagt die
BA würde dem Vorschlag der CDU
unterstützen nur die Regelsätze zu
erhöhen und sie wiederholen das jetzt
gerade sogar noch in der Debatte das
sind das ist die Form von Fake News die
sie immer wieder vortragen
und jeder dieser Fake News zu entkräften
dauert länger als in die Welt setzen und
deswegen möchte ich noch einen zweiten
Punkt bringen wo sie ja vielleicht jetzt
mal auch in der Sache was kritisieren
sie kritisieren das schon Vermögen das
sei viel zu viel
unser Ansicht nach ist wer kurzfristig
ins SGB 2 rein rutscht weil er
beispielsweise gar kein Anspruch auf
Arbeitslosengeld 1 hat selbstständiger
als Beispiel der sollte nicht sofort
sein Haus verkaufen müssen seine
Altersvorsorge aufbrauchen müssen und
sein Erspartes dann sagt der Kollege
Whittaker genau dann sagt der Kollege
Whittaker ist doch jetzt schon das
Altersvorsorge ausgenommen wird ist doch
jetzt schon der Fall ich sehe auch
nicken in ihrem rein gerade guckt man
aber genau ins Gesetz ist das nur die
staatlich geförderte Altersvorsorge es
ist nur Riester und rührup sobald sich
jemand entscheidet privat vorzusagen
vorvorzusorgen ist die nicht ausgenommen
und genau diese Feinheiten lassen sie
jedes Mal bei jedem Argument weg und
schüren damit eine Debatte die es bloß
nicht um die Sache geht lassen Sie uns
um die Sache diskutieren wir sind für
private Altersvorsorge bei
Selbstständigen wir sind dafür dass sie
auch in Aktien investieren können und
das auch geschützt wird wenn sie kurz
wissen es geht um den Entwurf eines
zwölften alles zu Änderungen des zweiten
Buches Sozialgesetzbuches
Sozialgesetzbuch und anderer Gesetze der
Einführung eines Bürgergeldes auf den
Drucksachen
20426 und 2043 60 abgegeben wurden 679
Stimmkarten mit ja haben bestimmt 385
mit Nein haben gestimmt 261 es gab 33
Enthaltungen
wir setzen nun die Abstimmung zu der
Beschluss bitte der Gesetzentwurf ist
damit angenommen das muss ich auch noch
sagen genau
er ist angenommen
das hat jetzt auch ein bisschen zu
Verwirrung geführt und die Abgeordneten
hätten durchaus gerne applaudiert aber
dadurch dass dieses Abstimmungsverfahren
heute etwas länger dauert ist das erst
so langsam ein gesickert ins Bewusstsein
also
bürgergeldgesetz hier angenommen in der
abschließenden Beratung und jetzt wird
noch mal aufgerufen ein Antrag der
Linken auch über den vietnamtlich
abgestimmt es geht um die Erhöhung der
Regelsätze noch mal
abendliche Abstimmung verlangt die
Abstimmung erfolgt wiederum in der heißt
Lobby sie haben jetzt zur Abgabe ihrer
Stimme nach Eröffnung der Abstimmung
diesmal 30 Minuten Zeit und wir werden
die Sitzungen nicht unterbrechen sie
sollten also nicht weglaufen ich bitte
die Schriftführerin Schriftführer die
vorgesehenen Plätze einzunehmen das ist
bereits der Fall dann eröffne ich die
dritte namentliche Abstimmung die Urnen
werden geschlossen um 11 Uhr